really on the
left I like him sitting on my
left I have a 15E
plan 15
plan it's 9 o' and I'm going to call the
Judiciary Committee to order and ask
everyone to rise and join me in the p
aliance Al to the flag of the United
States of America
theice thank you um a few housekeeping
notes we're going to limit testimony to
3 minutes we have a lot of cards here to
get through I'm sorry 2 minutes we're
doing two minutes today we have a lot of
cards and we have eight bills to get
through today as well so two-minute
limit if you've given written testimony
uh you don't have to read your testimony
you can just kind of Hit the highlights
we'll have your testimony here um also I
ask that there be no outbursts at all um
clapping cheering jering or anything
like that everyone has a right to be
heard here we want to make sure everyone
gets to speak um and if people are are
making a lot of noise it's just going to
cut into our time here we want to make
sure we can get everybody through so
with that I'm going to open up the
hearing on House Bill 148 and recognize
representative Kofa to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is Jim kofalt I represent
Hillsboro County District 32 uh
representing the towns of Wilton Temple
and new whip
switch um many of you may recognize this
as um the same bill word for word as
House Bill 396 which last year passed
both chambers of the
legislature um and was vetoed by the
governor this bill essentially addresses
three
situations um that are um I think
subject to uh quite a lot of discussion
in concern with respect to uh our
current um laws regarding discrimination
and those three situations are intimate
spaces meaning bathrooms and locker
rooms houses of
Correction and athletic competitions or
certain certain athletic competitions um
requiring speed and
strength what this bill does essentially
is to say that um our our current law
uh you know if this were to pass our law
would not consider separation of
biological Sexes under those uh three
situations to be
discriminatory it does not require the
separation of sexes so unlike House Bill
125 which we passed last year and has
been challenged in the courts uh this
does not mandate the separation um of uh
bathrooms locker rooms prisons and
sporting competitions uh based on
biological sex house bill 125 was
limited to sporting competitions but it
did actually mandate the separation of
sexes so uh just to give an example what
this does do is it allows um school
districts for
example to distinguish between
biological males and biological females
with respect to athletic
competitions a school district might
decide that that is entirely appropriate
for high school students who are uh
competing for potentially for
scholarships um or competing for state
championships or where there may be
actually uh some some physical dangers
involved with um you know Stronger
Faster biological males um competing in
certain Sports against biological
females the same school district might
decide that for intramural sports or for
um you know for
some Middle School sports or Elementary
School sports that there's really no
need to make those distinctions so it's
it's left um to a a a local school board
or Administration under those
circumstances to set reasonable
practical guidelines to make sure that
um everybody can work together and play
together with mutual
respect having served on a school board
and having served as a chair of a school
board
um I have seen that school boards are
often in a very precarious
position
um in my own experience there were a
number of transgender students who um
did not necessarily want to call
attention to um their differences they
wanted
to uh work well with everyone they
wanted everyone to get along and they
were willing to um work together with
the administration to make sure that
everybody's concerns were addressed
adequately at the same time we have seen
situations where that has not been in
the case two years ago uh when we held
the hearing for House Bill 396 we heard
from a mother in
Milford who um very tearfully told the
Judiciary Committee at the time about
her own experience as a survivor of
sexual violence all I want to do she
said is protect my 12-year-old
girl in that particular instance there
was a biological male in Milford
considerably older than this woman's
daughter who was routinely going into
the girls locker room um watching the
younger girls as they were getting
undressed as they were getting changed
and making fun of
them um this biological male
interestingly had a had a
girlfriend um but claimed that he was
trans transgender and um that that gave
him license to um to to have free reign
in the girls bathrooms and locker rooms
um I have had people Express a concern
that this bill is transphobic I've had
people Express a concern that uh there
is an underlying belief that transgender
people are um inherently
predatory I absolutely do not believe
that I have never said that
and I have never implied that what I
will say is that this provides a
loophole for people who may not actually
present themselves as transgender at
all to gain access to
spaces um that practically speaking they
should not have access
to
so unlike some other bills uh I
mentioned House Bill 125 that sort of
mandate the separation of sexes
um in sports or others other proposals
that would have mandated the separation
of sexes in bathrooms and locker rooms
this bill simply
says there is discretion School Board
should not be subject to
lawfare um threats from special interest
groups they should not be
um sort of put between a rock and a hard
place as the Milford school board was uh
the Milford school board at one point
took the um the sort of the baffling
position of covering up the urinals in
the boy room so that um every student
would be using a stall when they go to
the
bathroom
um as a society we are navigating
territory that we have not uh really had
to navigate before I am a firm believer
that we ought to respect Everyone by
virtue of their
Humanity um
and this bill quite honestly is you know
I have positioned it before and I will
continue to position it as this is the
can't we can't we all get a long Bill
and so um it is with that uh spirit that
I put forward House Bill 148 and um that
ends my testimony uh Mr chairman I will
take questions any questions
representative
Horgan well this is a pretty basic
question and you're talking about uh
biological sex um well terms you didn't
use were gender identity and gender
expression but and there SP lacks a
definition of biological sex so what do
you think it is and why does that matter
more than the person's gender identity
or gender expression so I just or does
it matter more than their gender
identity or gender expression so you're
because you do seem to does seem to
contemplate like forcing people to use
you know facilities or do things other
than what they would do they're based on
their gender identity and gender
Expressions I'm not sure what the
question is exactly well right well
there's no maybe I'll just start with
the basic one biological sex so like
what there's no definition of the bill
so what exactly is it so thank you for
the question representative so I I I
have had people pose the question
um of whether we ought to whether I
ought to have um
set out to Define biological sexs in the
bill uh practically speaking I think we
know what what males and females are we
have known that for thousands of years I
don't see a need to Define it and
um so I have chosen not to include that
in the
bill representative
TR yeah thanks and thanks for taking the
question I guess it's somewhat related
maybe to the question that
representative haran just asked um
I look at biological definitions of sex
and I see at least four possible ways
that you could do it which can be
different at different points in
people's lives and can also be different
at the same point in people's lives and
I'll list them and I wonder if you could
react to each of them
chromosomes
gonads hormones and sex secondary sexual
characteristics those are more possible
ways I can imagine I'm wondering without
a definition how might anyone use this
bill to um make
policy thank you for the question
so again I think there there is
a your
your your question implies that there's
confusion as to male and female and I
would assert once again I really do not
believe that that is the case
I think that we know what a biological
male is I think we know what a
biological female is and that there are
um some extraordinary cases that don't
clearly medically speaking don't clearly
fall into one category or
another to that I would say go back to
what I said before which is that this
bill um allows discretion and
latitude for local policy makers to
clarify those things for their own
purposes and set a policy that everyone
can live
with any other questions representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question do you agree that we cannot
provide equity for 100% of people 100%
of the time but we're obligated as a
society to provide safety for the
majority especially in sensitive
situations
thank you for the question I I think
that you know as I have talked about
this bill I have sometimes
mentioned um the need to protect young
girls in
particular that's probably influenced by
the story of the Milford mom that I
mentioned
earlier I did get an email from someone
who said young boys are concerned about
their privacy and modesty as
well
um so understanding that we have
different different needs um
different priorities um as
individuals there is no way we can
legislate respect for other
people um I I wish that we could but we
can't
um I always strive to treat people with
respect by virtue of their Humanity and
I urge everyone else to do the same
thing as far as um safety is concerned I
think there are potential safety
issues not necessarily as I said it it
doesn't have to be someone who who is
who truly identifies as transgender
sometimes it can be someone who has
really makes no pretense of identifying
as transgender except for the purposes
of accessing spaces that they should not
be in and I think those are the kinds of
things that we need to create some kind
of
mechanism some latitude to make
reasonable sensible policies um to avoid
those those kind of
situations thank
you representative Horgan uh hold on one
second representative rmo thank you for
uh taking my question thank you Mr chair
um I you referenced Governor senu VTO
from last year and I was thinking about
that earlier too because he had in
particular mentioned as Vito that HB
396 was seeking to solve problems that
had not presented themselves in New
Hampshire in his opinion and was
inviting unnecessary Discord as you said
the bill is the same now I am not
hearing from my community that there
have been um incidents or or concerns
about men coming into women's bathrooms
or vice versa can you tell I know you
saided the example of the Milford T can
you tell me where this concern other
instances where this is coming from
yes thank you for the question so I'm
aware of at least three school districts
where it has it has become a major issue
uh karge is one um Milford is one and
msic School District which is in my
district is also one
um I have also heard from legislators in
the state house that they have felt
uncomfortable using bathrooms in the
state house because there was a person
of the opposite sex in the bathroom with
them and were those a followup but we're
going to follow up goe and were those
instances where those were transgender
individuals who
were the other people felt uncomfortable
with um I in in the latter case I don't
actually know the details I just I have
heard someone say that it has been an
issue for them I have heard others
affirm that and I at least four or five
others say yes that has been an issue
and a concern as well you're trying to
address that with this bill I'm I'm
trying to
address generally speaking I'm trying to
address the the problem that we have no
recourse
when someone creates one of these
situations um there there's no there's
no latitude for reasonable judgment
there's no latitude for creating
policies where we all get along what
happens instead is um outside groups
tend to come into these school districts
and threaten lawsuits and it puts school
boards in a very very uncomfortable
situation so I don't know what uh what
policy would ensue uh at the State House
for example if this were to pass um but
I do know that it is a a serious concern
that has been expressed by a number of
people thank you representative hgan do
you have another
question uh I think I wave it off I was
going to ask him if there's any
documentation of the Milford situation
but um we thank we we know what there is
to know about it I think and the curar
situation has been amp hold on yeah so
you said you're going to wave off yes
but any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you just want to remind the people that
just got here strict two-minute limit on
your testimony um aside from the prime
sponsor of the bill and members we're
not going to have any followup questions
uh if you have a question just so we can
get through we have a lot of cards and
we have eight hearings today so
executive councelor
Hill followed by representative Wade
you'll be
next thank you very much Mr chairman
Representatives thank you for allowing
me to testify my name is Karen Leo Hill
I'm the executive counselor for district
2 representing 81 cities and towns New
Hampshire has been a leader in our
nation in anti-discrimination
protections for our residents consistent
with our Live Free or Die motto in 2018
the legislature added gender identity to
the list of protected groups as Governor
sonunu said last year in his veto
statement of this exact same bill
discrimination is unacceptable and runs
contrary to New Hampshire's Live Free or
Die spirit that still Rings true today
and Governor sonunu V message still
Rings true today HB 148 is contrary to
the um prevention of discrimination in
New Hampshire it is contrary to the Live
Free or Die motto and it would be a
major step backwards in New Hampshire
please vote and expedient to legislate
on HB 148 thank
you any questions seeing none thank
you representative uh Alice Wade
followed by representative
seig morning members of the committee
and thank you Mr chair uh my name is
Alice Wade I represent straford district
15 do Ward 2 I strongly oppose this bill
because it serves no legitimate public
benefit and only serves to harass trans
people for existing I myself am a trans
woman and I'm going to bet that most of
you would not have known that unless I
had told you all of my documents say
female I have had bottom surgery I have
had voice therapy and I've been
transitioning for over six years now
just this morning I used the women's
restroom down that
Hall no issues I have used the's
restroom for six years in public no
disruptions no one has ever called me
out for it or anything but even if I did
not pass as a ciswoman I would still
deserve to use the restroom and public
in peace just like everyone else if
we're talking about
enforcement let's pretend that this law
passes in some County decides that they
want to implement this and to prevent
trans women from using the restroom how
are we checking your original birth
certificate at the door nobody brings
those around anywhere you know are we
talking genital inspections for anybody
to enter a restroom and how is that in
anyone's best
interest if you truly believe in the
goal of this law even if you do you
should not vote to pass it unless you
can clearly answer the question on how
this would be enforced in Florida people
risk felony charges for using the
restroom in Texas there are counties
that offer $10,000 bounties on trans
people's heads for using the
restroom if this law passes a county
could Implement that here in New
Hampshire there are travel advisories
for Trans people I cannot go to Florida
even on vacation I cannot move there for
work because it would be illegal for me
to live there in
public yourself in my shoes imagine
there's a padlock on every public
restroom and you have to hold it in for
eight hours that is unreasonable it is
not fair to anyone and I'm happy to
answer any questions any questions
representative
pel thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you please
submit um that article or some
documentation about that $110,000 Bounty
please I'm happy to email it to you but
it's very well publicly known that there
are counties in Texas that for the
record I would like yes
absolutely any other questions seeing
none thank you thank
you representative Lawrence seig
followed by Betsy
Harrington good morning committee uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my testimony for the record I am
la in selig I represent the town of
Durham which is straford County District
10 and um I strongly oppos this bill uh
I'm I'm the parent of two children my
children swam on the swim team they had
transgender athletes on the swim team
the kids all changed in the bathrooms
they took showers in the bathrooms they
all had individual stalls and used what
they needed to because kids don't like
to change in front of any other kid just
like adults generally don't like to
change their clothes in front of any
other adult it's not an issue um this
bill in my opinion is extremely
discriminatory um it I was listening to
the prime sponsor talk about the woman
who believed her child was being
sexually harassed by an older male
person I would venture to say that it
had nothing to do with the fact that
they were in the bathroom if there's a
cisgender male going into a girl's
bathroom and harassing young girls that
is not an issue about trans people
that's an issue about a cisgender male
or an older male harass ing a young girl
and there are legal actions that can be
taken when that happens if someone is
harassing or stalking you there are
legal actions and legal protections um
in terms of biological sex it's a label
that's been assigned to a person based
on a number of physical characteristics
or other characteristics but that
differentiation may happen at any time
at certain points in our lives we have
different levels of estrogen we have
different levels of testosterone I had a
very very very old gynecologist tell me
that as my body stops produc proding
estrogen I'll stop being female I'm
pretty sure I'm staying female my whole
life I haven't changed yet whether my
body produces estrogen or not you know I
I continue to be what I believe and know
to be myself I will say I used the stall
next to representative Wade earlier
today I had no problem about that as
long as she's not peeking in my stall
and I'm not peeking in her stall and we
can all pee in peace and wash our hands
and make sure we leave the bathroom neat
that's the important factor so if we
apologize representative that's your
time okay if we could please stop
discrimin against people I would
appreciate that I oppose this bill okay
any questions seeing none thank you
thank
you Betsy
Harrington followed by
Rosemary is it
emic hi my name is Betsy Harrington I'm
from daring New Hampshire I'm here to
represent somebody who is experienced it
like for real my boys play soccer their
girlfriends play soccer too one
girlfriend refused to play this season
because there was a boy playing on the
other team at karge a boy playing
against the law it was violating state
law that child did not have an
injunction to play um so the girlfriend
refused to play five girls refuse to
play and it's really
affecting the kids and so I'm here to
represent those kids who it really is
repres really who it is really affecting
I went to that game we played anyway we
had five JV girls go to that game and so
it was a complete blowout uh the the
game never even got towards the goal and
um the player is the goalie and so it
was really nothing ever happened it was
just a blowout and felt very unfair but
I found out the next day that the
player's father was a sex offender
violating his bail conditions at that
game and I feel like when you introduce
one breaking of the law it it says well
if they're going to break the law here I
can just totally break the law there too
and introduce more dangerous and so I
feel like we need to stick to the law
the law was that boys were not supposed
to be playing on girls designated teams
and yet we blurred it and allowed some
to play and it was I I don't want to
swear but like a show it was there
was media kids weren't playing kids were
upset it's just going to keep happening
if that's what we keep doing and it's
always going to be that c same kind of
show just crazy and bringing media and
kids won't play and drama and if we just
separate it by boys and girls it's
simple the way it's always been so I'm
just here to tell you it's been awful
and I would like it to go back to the
way it was we need this
bill i' be happy to answer questions any
questions seeing none thank
you thank
you Rosemary emic
followed by Steph
scare uh Dear honorable members of the
Judiciary Committee my name is Rosie
Emer and I live in hooks at New
Hampshire I'm here today as a sister
cisgendered woman and as a parent of a
young trans child who oppose this
bill um my child is non-binary and uses
they them pronouns um for them this
means that they don't feel like a girl
or a boy and this has made decisions
around bathrooms and changing rooms
pretty painstaking and very anxiety
provoking for my child and myself alike
um they have used the bathroom that
matches their assigned sex at Birth by
choice and have had to deal with
uncomfortable questions and harassment
and so this bill that you're proposing
is going to fix a problem that doesn't
exist and cause more problems for my
child uh American Pediatric um American
Association of Pediatrics put out a
study that says that bathroom
restrictions and locker room
restrictions actually lead to 1.2 to 2
and a half times more likelihood of
sexual assault for Trans uh and
non-binary folks and so this is not the
let's all get along bill that's not what
it's doing um my child uh who is 8 years
old wrote some testimony which I'd like
to read really quickly and then I'll be
done my name is Emily and I use they
them pronouns I 8 years old and I live
in hookit I'm a trans kid and since
transitioning it's been an entirely
different life it's been scarier because
some people don't understand what trans
people are going through through but I
like it more than how it was before
before it felt like something was
missing and now I feel like me I like
being a trans skid I like that I've met
people that support me and other trans
people I'm here to ask you to stop this
bathroom band bill it's important to me
to be able to use the bathroom that
makes me feel most safe I've had people
ask me why I'm in a certain bathroom
it's scary and makes me anxious and
uncomfortable to answer questions about
what bathroom you're in and why you use
it people guess on how you look and
sound and sometimes they can be wrong I
think trans people should have the right
to do all the things everybody else can
do like be safe and use the bathroom
without questions please support trans
kids like me by stopping this bathroom
bill that's your time if you have
written testimony you want to turn in I
do yeah down the end we'll be fine thank
you Stephen scare did I get that
right followed by Wendy
Stallings Steven scare nashwa good
morning chairman and distinguished
members of the House Judiciary meet
committee I support this bill with one
important caveat I've got the same
concern as representative Horgan about
the lack of definition the Riley gains
Foundation won't support this bill
because it's missing that and I suggest
and it's on the second page of my
testimony the definition for the
purposes of the subsections SE shall be
recognized based solely on a person's
reproductive biology and genetics at
Birth the the sexual binary is an
objective reality each of us here is a
product of one small gam produced by a
male and one large gam Pro produced by a
female there's no other way humans can
reproduce sex isn't assigned at Birth
it's determined at conception and
observed with almost perfect accuracy at
Birth or earlier the fact that our
Medical Association say otherwise is a
testimony to their ideological
corruption but gender identity ities are
imaginary and based on emotions
stereotypes and circular reasoning
according to New Hampshire law gender
identity means I quote a person's gender
related identity and how do we know if
someone's transgender according to
former director of dartman cells
transgender health program John turko
quote there is only one test I know of
to determine gender identity and that is
to ask that person and so a gender
identity is a gender identity a
transgender person is someone who says
he's transgender and a girl is someone
who says that he or she is a girl none
of this makes sense I've heard this the
LED fantasy that excluding males from
female spaces would require genital
inspections I can't take this seriously
when those selling the story have no
idea what a girl is and have already
established laws forcing girls to strip
in front of their male um class I
apologize sir that's your time thank you
any
questions seeing none thank
you Wendy Stallings followed by Beth
scare thank you distinguished
Representatives um I appreciate the work
that you do my name is Wendy Stallings
I'm from exitor New Hampshire as a
mother I oppose this bill as an educator
I oppose this bill as a scientist I
oppose this bill and everything the
person said before me has been disproved
by
science as a human I oppose this bill
and as a Christian I oppose this bill I
want not offer two insights I
appreciated representative Perez's
question about protecting the vast
majority of people so I pose this
hypothetical situation to
highlight the Injustice of this
bill it is far more likely that our
children will be sexually abused in
church than they will be sexually abused
in a bathroom by a trans
person if someone were to propose a bill
saying that anyone ident who identifies
as Christian should not be allowed to
use a bathroom because I knew somebody
once who said he was a Christian and he
sexually abused somebody we would all
agree that that was
discrimination now if you substitute
that with
trans it's still
discrimination
second I know students I know people
I've taught thousands of children
thousands we don't always look like the
gender in our underwear the only way to
police this is to sexually molest people
by checking their genitalia that is the
only way to police this are we willing
as represent representatives to sexually
molest every person who doesn't conform
to the way a woman should look or the
way a man should look when they enter a
restroom we moved to the
Northeast to get rid of these laws I
apologize but that's your time thank you
any questions at all seeing none thank
you Beth Beth
scare that's going to be followed by by
Devin
Church hi um my name is Beth scare my
grandmother from nashwa and I'm here
supporting HB 148 um this is the Live
Free or Die State and Governor senu made
a terrible mistake in
2018 when he signed HB 1319 prohibiting
discrimination based on gender identity
into law he thought he was integrating
lunch counters in the Deep South but
what he was doing was stripping away the
privacy and safety of women and girls an
estimated 91% of victims of rape and
sexual assault are female and 9% are
male nearly
99% of perpetrators are male in a
Swedish study on a population of
individuals who had undergone sex
reassignment the researchers State male
to females retained a male part pattern
regarding criminality the same was true
regarding violent
crime a large percentage of trans
identifying males also known as trans
women are sexually attracted to women
they transition because they have a
sexual fetish called
autophilia if a person has one sexual
fetish they are very likely to have
other sexual fetishes and here in Nash
in Nashville we had a male State rap
Stacy lton who identified as a woman was
sexually attracted to women and was
charged with soliciting and distributing
pornographic pictures of local toddlers
thankfully he's being housed in a man's
p in a Men's prison should men with
autophilia and other sexual Fe fetishes
being be given access to women's and
girls spaces of intimate privacy or
women's prisons segregation by
biological sex can be a good and
necessary thing it's not like racial
segregation let let Planet Fitness
choose to allow men into their women's
locker rooms women can choose whether or
not to join that gym and risk seeing a
man undressing or a man watching them
undress or they can join a gym that
respects their need for privacy and
safety my testimony against HB 1319 the
non-discrimination bill has been
immortalized in the Hulu documentary
changing the game and it is still
relevant today I apologize that's your
time okay you have written testimony you
can turn it in you and I'll I'll email
it too because I have links to to verify
everything I said thanks thank
you Devin
Church followed by Nancy
Brennan good morning um members of the
House Judiciary Committee my name is
Devon Church a longtime resident of
hookit I'm here today to urge you to
prioritize the safety of women and girls
by opposing House Bill 148 as you are
aware bills like this have been
introduced in several states often
Justified as a means of protecting women
and girls in spaces where privacy is
essential as a father of a young girl
with disabilities the husband of a woman
with whom I've spent the last 24 years
of my life nothing is more important to
me than their safety I am however deeply
concerned by the potential harm this
bill could cause instead of enhancing
safety it could create significant risks
one critical oversight is the failure to
recognize the existence of transgender
men should this bill pass transgender
men like myself would be forced to use
women's restrooms and locker rooms while
my voice May reveal my transgender
status my appearance rarely does meaning
any man whether transgender or not could
claim to be a transgender man to access
women's private spaces this raises
another pressing concern how would
enforcement of this bill work would
individuals be required to prove their
sex to access sex segregated spaces such
a policy would not only be impractical
but would also expose women and girls to
unnecessary harassment and invasive
questioning and private spaces this does
not sound like protection it sounds like
harm finally I must address the glaring
contradiction in the bill it claims that
the state is fundamentally committed to
treating all persons without
discrimination and with equal dignity
and respect but its Provisions would
effectively exclude transgender
individuals from public life denying
someone access to something as basic as
a restroom contradicts any genuine
commitment to the equality and freedom
it is inconsistent with the values we
hold dear in New Hampshire and is
Unworthy of our great state thank you
for your time and consideration I
strongly urge to oppose House Bill 148
for the sake of safety dignity and the
freedom of all Granite
Staters that was two minutes thank you
perfect any questions at all sorry thank
you Nancy Brennan followed by Sarah
Terrell could would you give me the time
please I've been out in the hall it's
going to be two a two minute limit two
minute thank you so my name is Nancy
Brennan I'm from
we and I am here in opposition to this
bill I have been in opposition to these
bills for the last seven eight years and
I have testified and I have sent studies
combating what some of the anti-trans
people are trying to pretend is
real before the last presidential
election we had a candidate who's now
our president who spent
222 million dollars to other the trans
Comm community and make them look like
evil people and that gives permission
for things to happen like the um you
stick to the bill that we're we're
speaking of here rather than I am this
bill this Bill gives people permission
to discriminate no matter what it says
it does and it also gives people
permission to go after transgender
people I don't know if you read it
should have been on the front page of
every paper about the young man who was
tortured and killed by five people a
young transgender man was tortured for
two months
we had a speaker
earlier who thought it was okay to bring
up the legal status of a transgender
woman that kind of hate should not stand
you shouldn't allow it to stand please
listen to the testimony please do some
research on what transgender really is
and what interex is and how different
some people are and mostly let's be
kind thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you Sarah
Terrell followed by Aubrey
fredman good
morning thank you for taking the time to
hear public testimony on HB 148 today my
name is Sarah Terell I am Al lifelong
resident of New Hampshire I was
incredibly proud when in 2018 our state
came together to pass strong
anti-discrimination protections ensuring
no one could be denied dignity and
safety based on age sex gender identity
race Creed color marital status familial
status disability or a national origin
that was a moment of progress and
Humanity today I am horrified that HB
148 seeks to strip those protections
from one of our most vulnerable
populations my daughter is transgender
she is 16 years old and like any
teenager she is busy navigating School
driver's education Sports and her first
job she faces the same challenges as her
peers homework friendships and planning
for the future what she should not have
to face is additional fear and anxiety
imposed on her by her own state
government like everyone else she just
wants to use a restroom or locker room
in peace she wants to get in do what she
needs to do and get out she's not a
predator the implication that
transgender people are a danger by
default is both offensive and false HB
148 will not protect privacy or safety
it will do the exact opposite forcing
transgender people into spaces where
they clearly do not belong puts them at
risk my daughter has long hair she wears
butterfly sweatshirts paints her nails
and loves lip gloss I cannot imagine a
world where she or anyone in a men's
restroom would feel comfortable or safe
if she were to forced to walk in she
does not want to pass by Men At urinals
any more than they want a young woman
walking by them we all agree that
discrimination is wrong the bipartisan
support for New Hampshire's 2018
anti-discrimination law proved that HB
148 is a step backward
it's unnecessary harmful and an insult
to the very principles of fairness and
dignity that we uphold transgender
people are people they deserve to be
treated with the same respect and
Humanity as anyone else they are not a
threat just because of who they are
please help me keep my child safe vote
itl on HB 148 thank you thank you if you
have a written testimony that you want
to turn in we'd appreciate it thank
you Aubrey fredman followed by the
caleff
bitler uh Mr chairman committee members
uh Aubrey Friedman I live in Bridgewater
I speak in support of this bill so let's
talk about the prisons and the detention
facilities I'd say that's the biggest
area of concern here uh if the state is
going to incarcerate women then it is
responsible for the safety of those
women and if you have a a biological
maale that somehow gets into the prison
uh you know under you know the guys of
well they get in there uh there could be
abuse and it's really a safety issue and
actually the taxpayer would be on the
hook so I'd say that is the the biggest
concern here is uh safety in uh uh
detention facilities should keep
separate um as far as the uh changing
rooms and all that kind of stuff um I
know it's uh they share they in like in
Europe they do share changing rooms men
and women that's not that uncommon uh
but that's Europe this is America and
here we're still kind of separate on
that and a man probably wouldn't care
actually if a woman uh goes into the uh
men's changing room or whatever but I
think many women do not like that they
feel like that's an invasion of their
space and let's honor their privacy and
that's those are the reasons I support
this Bill thank you thank you any
questions at all seeing none thank you
thank
you Michaela
fisler followed by Lauren
Irwin good morning members of the House
Judiciary Committee for the record my
name is Michaela Fishler and I'm from
Manchester I'm here to express my
opposition to house spill 148 as a spill
allows for public and private
institutions to discriminate against
transgender individuals to begin I want
to point out the fact that when it comes
to bathroom and locker room use
requiring individuals to use one
corresponding to their sex assigned
birth rather than their current gender
identity or presentation your mandating
scenarios where someone who looks like a
man now must enter a women's restroom
because they were assigned female at
Birth and someone who looks like a woman
now must enter a men's restroom because
they were assigned male at Birth that
goes against any argument for safety and
comfort for anyone involved I don't want
to go into a men's restroom and trans
women get assaulted by men as well I
also want to bring up the third
circumstance proposed in this bill the
biological sex classification and
Correctional Facilities Bill claims the
policy changes will protect the privacy
and safety but it would should be
abundantly clear that forcibly placing
transgender individuals in with those
that share their so-called biological
sex POS an immense privacy and
especially safety risk to them this bill
throughout devalues the privacy and
safety of transgender individuals but
this specific case tops the rest
additionally the inclusion of mental
health institutions feels especially
callous as taking extra vulnerable
individuals and putting them in hostile
situations is
abusive as a wise old Jedi once said
fear is the path to the dark side fear
leads to anger anger leads to hate hate
leads to suffering bills like this Stoke
any existing fears and anger Paving the
way for legitimizing hate and
legislating suffering instead of
perpetuating the cycle I encourage
everyone to remember transgender people
are human beings just like them if
you're afraid just try and understand if
you're confused just ask and we can all
talk this isn't the end of civilized
society none of this is new to humanity
we can handle this thank you thank you
any questions seeing none thank
you Lauren
Irwin followed by Lind
jaos thank you members of the committee
my name is Lauren Irwin I've lived in
New Hampshire for more than 30 years I'm
an employment attorney with the law firm
of Upton and Hatfield based here in
conquer I strongly oppose this Bill
thank you for the opportunity for
letting me speak about
it I oppose this bill because it takes
away existing legal protections and
rights for transgender people in New
Hampshire I also am the parent of a
transgender child in 2018 only seven
years ago this this the legislature
passed and the governor signed into law
a bill that specifically added gender
identity as a protected class this was a
done on a bipartisan basis and signed by
Republican governor sonunu in the
process of passing that law I want to
bring your attention to the fact that
the house Judiciary Committee this
committee at the time issued a majority
committee report in which describing the
intent of the bill it stated that the
bill would add gender identity to New
Hampshire's existing Human Rights Act
which at the time already uh included
the other categories the report goes on
to State and I've given copies for
everyone in this committee I've
submitted that this morning it would
prohibit discrimination in employment
housing public spaces such as
restaurants businesses hospitals based
on gender identity it was noted that the
committee had heard many cases of actual
discrimination from transgender
individuals and that the bill was
supported by employment attorneys the
Human Rights Commission and the
Bia in addition the committee heard
support from the chiefs of Police
Association who explained that the bill
explicitly says that a person's gender
identity cannot be asserted for an
improper purpose such as using a
bathroom or locker room to commit a
crime we still have our Criminal
protections here in New Hampshire with
our existing law the committee explained
that they heard testimony about the high
rate of preventable suicide in the
transgender Community noting that a
staggering 41% of transgender people
reported attempting suicide compared to
1.6% in the general
population extra time I apologize I urge
you to oppose this bill I've represented
transgender people they are very
valuable members of the new ire
Community any questions at
all it's a practical question so
looking looking for your testimony email
streams so I guess both Lauren and Irwin
are names that have multiple spellings
so which spelling should I be searching
for oh sure uh l a u r n i r w i n i met
I I met Upton in Hatfield and I've lived
in New Hampshire for over 30 years all
right thanks any other questions at
all okay at this point I'm going to
do a quick recess on House Bill 148 and
I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill 520 and recess that hearing
till March 5th at 9:00 a. so anyone
that's here for House Bill 520 that will
be recessed until March 5th no no hang
on so I'm G to close that hearing and
reopen the hearing on House Bill
148 Lind
jcos followed by
brenos hello members of the Judiciary
Committee I stand in strong opposition
to HB 148 this mean-spirited Bill allows
discrimination in restrooms against
transgender people and anyone who has
perceived it all as all as at all gender
non-conforming
in 2017 and 2018 I managed the
successful effort to update New
Hampshire's law against discrimination
to include protections for transgender
people in employment housing and public
spaces which passed with broad
bipartisan support opponents of the non
of non-discrimination tried to further
the false bathroom Predator myth but in
the seven years since the
non-discrimination law passed there have
been no uptick in safety incidents in
restrooms many times over in 2018 people
who know and love transgender people had
to State time and time again the simple
obvious fact that we all care about
safety and privacy in restrooms
including transgender people there is no
evidence to support otherwise
villainizing our community when we are
not the predators in the bathroom is
fueling a long-standing anti-lgbtq
stereotype at one 2017 meeting I helped
organize between constituents and one
state representative that state
representative stated that he was afraid
of trans women in the restroom and the
psychologist constituent explained how
important it is for all of us to talk
back to our unfounded fears I am asking
this committee to do the same I suspect
the authors of this bill did not
explicitly Target employment
discrimination because they knew it
would be incredibly unpopular and also
con unconstitutional as the Supreme
Court ruled that employment
discrimination against gay and
transgender people is unlawful sex
discrimination however this bill is an
employment discrimination bill because
restrooms cannot be separated from
employment if employers are allowed to
discriminate in restrooms their
transgender employees cannot safely use
the restrooms at their job jobs what if
every job a transgender person is
applying to allows discrimination where
is the transgender employee supposed to
go for all people including transgender
people being able to use the restroom is
essential to being able to navigate all
parts of public life how will this
that's your time I'll email a longer
version of the committee um of my
testimony to the committee happy to take
questions any questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr
chairman you indicate that there is a
problem with this language under
employment law as I read this language
this new language imposes no new uh
strictures and impositions on uh private
employers so can you explain to me how
there could be any issue under
employment law uh and it's entirely a
matter for those employers is it not by
saying that anyone May discriminate
against transgender people in the
restroom um that is allowing employers
to potentially discriminate in restrooms
and places of employment for both
employees and um and people that
frequent their business um from the
outside thank
you thank you any other questions seeing
none thank you and again I apologize for
the two-minute limit but if you have
testimony you want to email to us
afterwards we'll certainly take it we
encourage it Bren
nus that's going to be followed by cerra
muns thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee
my name is Bren ninos I am a excuse me I
am a mother of
three and um the value of treating all
persons without discrimination and with
equal dignity and respect is
fundamentally at odds with classifying
biological sex in terms of access to
laboratory facilities or locker rooms
athletic or sporting events and in our
institutions as a cisgender woman I do
not feel unsafe if a transwoman uses the
same bath bathroom or facilities as I do
as a parent I do not feel my cisgender
children will be unsafe if they share a
bathroom or a facility or sports teams
with a child who is trans I feel
strongly that trans people will be
deeply harmed by exclusion when they
cannot use the bathroom the locker they
cannot participate in the sports knowing
that I am not at risk at all when a
transperson fully participates in all
the same activities to which cisgender
adults and children have a right to
participate and knowing that a trans
child who is excluded isolated or denied
dignity is far more likely to engage in
risk-taking behaviors per the family
acceptance project we should consider
the safety and well-being of all
children through fostering inclusion and
acceptance over fear and exclusion
I oppose HB 148 thank you thank you any
questions at all seeing none thank
you Cameron
muns followed by David Maxim
Jr awesome uh thank you very much for
allowing me to speak my name is Cameron
muns I'm a Manchester resident and have
been so for 38 some odd years of my 41
years of life um I'm a trans citizen of
this live fre I State this bill is an
indisputable attack on the trans
citizens of New Hampshire and mocks any
freedoms this state claims claiming this
is part of a law of a law against
discrimination uh then set parameters
after is in fact discrimination in the
most perverse way
in the interest of the state's
commitment to privacy rights unless you
want to claim a responsibility for state
sponsored critique criticism and
questioning of your citizens genitalia
of all ages I would expect you to vote
no on
hp48 I am a trans citizen of this live
for your die State this bill is an
indisputable attack on the trans
citizens of New Hampshire and mocks any
freedoms this state claims claiming this
is a a part of a law against
discrimination then set parameters after
is in fact discrimination in the most
perverse way in the interest of the
state's commitment to privacy rights
unless you want to claim responsibility
for state sponsored critique criticism
and questioning of your citizens
genitalia of all ages I would expect you
to vote no on HP
148 I'm a trans citizen of this live for
your die State this bill is an
indisputable attack on the trans
citizens of New Hampshire and mocks any
freedoms this state claims and yes I'm
continuing to repeat myself because we
are still here doing this and it doesn't
seem like any of you are
listening we need you to listen to the
actual people that you represent and not
fear-based
hypotheticals and not bills that are
given to you with
no science or proof or research or
anything included and yet you ask us
apologize
sites right so maybe do that for your
representatives please oppose this Bill
thank
you David Maxim Jr followed by Doris
basell good morning thank you so much
for giving me the opportunity to speak
uh my name is David Maxon Jr I'm a
hookset resident educated and proud
Granite stator today I stand before you
on behalf of my transgender students
co-workers family members and fellow
citizens of New Hampshire all of whom
share a simple yet profound desire to
live free in our Granite State this bill
however runs counter to the very values
that have long defined the granite state
the transgender Community has always
been here accessing public facilities
that align with their gender identity
without issue it was only in recent
years that extremist groups and farri
political leaders began to scapegoat and
vilify trans individuals inciting a
social Panic through deceptive
accusations aimed at erasing their very
existence I ask you how do we en enforce
restroom classifications based on
biological sex without resorting to
unconstitutional and discriminatory
practices how is how is to decide how
biological sex is defined and policed
moreover how can mental health
professionals provide compassionate
effective care while dismissing a
patient's identity how can they uphold
their duty to do no harm when over
700,000 transgender students have
succumbed to Suicide not because of who
they are but because Society has
legislated their rights dignity and very
existence away gender dysphoria is
recognized as a legitimate mental health
condition in the diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental disorders
also known as the dsm5 so how can we
possibly claim to protect mental health
while invalidating the very individual
seeking care the the Stark reality is is
that we cannot instead this bill
threatens to incite further violence
against transgender individuals and dis
dismantle critical protections against
discrimination based on gender identity
I want a New Hampshire where every
person is free to build their own life
no one uh not one where the government
dictates the validity of their existence
disturbingly during the time I have
spoken an estimated 13 to 24 transgender
Americans have attempted suicide okay
thank you so much any questions any
questions at all seeing none thank you
thank
you uh Karen is it uh Dario
odeno Doris basell you'll be uh next
after this
good
morning this is for submission in
opposition to House Bill 148 as the
mother of an incredibly wonderful
intelligent and kind transgender adult
son from this supposed Live Free or Die
State I take issue with those who try to
diminish legislate or outright ban his
mere existence forgive me for being
under the impression that our
constitution grants all of its citizens
equal protection under the law complete
with unalienable rights freedoms and
liberties with unalienable meaning
impossible to give away or to take away
or give up as a former teacher and small
business owner I was very fortunate to
meet a variety of adults families and
children from all walks of life My
Religion taught me to be kind
compassionate and to help the less
fortunate and for that I am
grateful Society is often unkind to and
judgmental about individuals who are
quote unquote
different I make it a point to learn
about topics with which I am famili
unfamiliar and no little about excluding
groups of people because they don't
conform to our pre determined
expectations and biases is petty wrong
and
immoral with respect to houseal Bill 148
I read that a whopping
.8% of athletes are
transgender given all the pressing
issues and challenges in our society why
is this even being
legislated it's precisely this kind of
Bill and narrow-mindedness that promotes
and fuels existing culture
Wars reality and statistics tell us the
trans population is already the target
of bullying threats and heinous actions
I apologize that's your time that's my
time that's your time yes is that two
minutes two
minutes any
questions New Hampshire you are better
than this thank you Karen Danielle
Danielle
you don't need to speak okay Vivian
Murphy followed by Courtney
Reid thank you for this opportunity to
speak my name is Vivian Murphy I'm from
Rochester New Hampshire and many of the
previous speakers have more eloquently
said what I was going to say so I will
as you ask narrow this
down part of the problem I think is
people that support this build they do
not see us and I'm speaking as a
transgender woman as women because of a
genetic anomaly you assume that we are
men and you expect us to act like men
that thought process by itself is pretty
sad and
damning this bill seems punitive and
vindictive we less than 1% as was
alluded to of the population it also
seems that it's fixated on trans women
we have had a few trans men here to
testify and I thank them for their
bravery and being
here um we are not transitioning to
something we are shedding the lies that
our bodies tell and finally being who we
are meant to
be biological classifications do exist
XX XY xxy xxy y all manners of
variations which is why sex isn't
classified as binary you can't have a
binary classification system with more
than two configurations even if they are
the dominant
configurations all we're asking for is
our constitutional promise of life
liberty and the pursuit of
happiness yet we're demonized
dehumanized legislated against
physically attacked emotionally attacked
and tortured our beloved State touts its
motto Live Free or Die with what little
time I have left on this Earth I plan to
do
that I guess that's all I have to say
that's your time anyway so that's I
appreciate it any questions at
all seeing none thank you very much
thank you Courtney Reid
followed
by uh is it male Jax
jocks good morning members of the
Judiciary Committee uh for the record my
name is Courtney Reid I serve as policy
Advocate with the ACLU of New Hampshire
and I'm speaking in opposition to this
bill uh primarily because HB
148 permits
discrimination uh with an ultimate
effect of making transgender people
unsafe and unwelcome in public
life this bill with no clear enforcement
mechanism threatens the policing of
bodies and emboldens individuals to act
cruelty in stores schools workplaces and
other Civic spaces and unfortunately it
means that we would undo meaningful
bipartisan work done only several years
ago that made our state more inclusive
and welcoming and all of that in
disregard of long-standing
hardfought anti-discrimination laws at
the federal
level I want to Echo some of the data
that was brought forward about how when
we have inclusive policies ones that
allow individuals to access the restroom
that aligns with their gender we see
reductions in rates of assault uh and
violence specifically on transgender
women and when the inverse is true when
we have bills like this in place where
individuals can't access facilities that
they need we actually see increased
rates of assault and violence and so
again I think this begs the question of
what the purpose of this bill is because
there is nothing unsafe or invasive
about a transgender person accessing a a
facility and we're claiming a right to
privacy in public spaces that are not
private um certainly there are questions
about how this bill would conflict with
uh Federal protections like title 7
barring I apologize but that's your time
sure are there any question take
questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your testimony could you
explain in list listening to to your
testimony I didn't hear anything that
you said that was in conflict with the
testimony that the the prime sponsor
representative kofar presented this
morning so could you explain what it is
about his his testimony and his bill
that you take issue
with thank you for the question
representative um if there's a specific
point I would appreciate an elaboration
but I
can talk through that the key point I'll
simplify my question is there something
specific in what representative cofort
said this morning that you would
disagree
with I don't recall thank you for the
followup I don't recall a a specific
point of the sponsor's testimony that I
can speak to but uh the aclu's position
to this bill is that it fundamentally
would permit discrimination against
transgender people in different areas of
life in violation of title 7 in Title 9
and the pr prison rape elimination act
they're also constitutional concerns
regarding 14th Amendment equal
protection rights and eth Amendment
rights uh about cruel and unusual
punishment in prisons and jails and when
policies like this have been challenged
or inclusive policies have been
challenged the courts overwhelmingly
have cited in favor that these policies
violate Title 9 and title 7
representative Horgan um thank you very
much I was looking over your written
testimony you referred to the
transgender offender manual put up by
the Bureau of Prisons and I know that's
an issue for correctional facilities at
all levels and
uh probably shouldn't say this by I know
the the former State ref who's in a
federal prison for what our horrific
crimes I'm pretty sure she doesn't want
to be in either gender's federal prison
or state prison but um I haven't spoken
to her since she was incarcerated but is
there a question here yes the question
is is this transgender offend of manual
as far as you and you may not know this
is this still still being used is this
one of the many things in in the the
federal government many federal
government things that have been
disrupted by the events of the last
month or
so thank you for your question
representative uh in the testimony uh
I've cited the New Hampshire Department
of Corrections policy which uses those
federal guidelines uh and follows um a
case by casee assessment of where to
place transgender individuals
considering their own safety risks this
is the federal policy as well uh after
the recent executive order um about uh
trans transgender inmates housing
placements this has been challenged in
the courts and they're actually has been
um a temporary restraining order placed
in in light of that uh executive order
noting that when that EO was rolled out
there actually were no legitimate claims
of violence or safety concerns uh that
were raised by the federal department of
corrections and um you can see that in
my testimony but I'm happy to highlight
that in a follow-up email okay thank you
thanks representative tur yeah thank you
and thanks for taking the question um my
reading of this bill um suggests that uh
as was stated before um the definition
of how uh biological sex would be
defined is wide open and as as the as
the co- sponsor said you know based on
perception um the bill also seems to
allow that definition to be
applied uh without any constraints as to
how the definition would interact with
um the processes of you know prisons and
bathrooms and sports um I guess my
question is do you agree with those two
things and do you know of any other law
in our state that um is open to
interpretation like
that thank you for your question I just
want to uh make sure I'm understanding
right
um am I aware of any other state law
that permits segregation based on
biological sex in this way of this
bill that allows segregation of people
based on an an an non-specifically
defined um of parameters or and doesn't
prescribe how that definition would be
applied thank you for your question
representative to my knowledge I am not
aware of any bill that does this aside
from the current uh uh Sports band
that's being challenged in the courts
right
now any other questions representative
perz thank you thanks for taking did I
hear you say that um in a public
restroom that people do not have a right
to
privacy thank you for your uh your
question representative Perez uh I had
stated that
individuals in support of this bill are
claiming a right to privacy in spaces
that are not private that means shared
facilities and that is actually coming
from a ruling out of the third circuit
where an inclusive policy was uh
challenged and was actually struck was
upheld uh on grounds of privacy and I'm
happy to relay the uh the ruling for you
from the third
circuit any other questions seeing none
thank you thank
you m Jax followed by Kelly
Warner Dear honorable Dear honorable
members of the House Judiciary Committee
my name is m Jac I'm a 17-year-old girl
from new and a junior at kirar Regional
High School and I'm here to testify an
opposition of
hp48 I'm a teenager trying to live my
life and go through the day at school
doing my school workor talking with my
friends and playing sports with them
despite this I am pered as a threat for
no reason other than the utilization of
fear as a political tactic throughout
the day I sometimes need to use the
bathroom like any other student this is
nothing but a normal part of my day I
use the bathroom and I am gone no harm
done to anyone else and no one's privacy
is compromised Banning me from the
restroom does nothing but pin me as a
pariah in school using the male restroom
would be dangerous because as the entire
School knows and has known for years
that I am not a male in the male
restroom I would face bullying for my
identity not to mention the
psychological harm by being forced to be
someone I'm not the same applies to
locker rooms whether using them before a
gym class or a sport I may face the same
issues or even but even worse school is
where I spend a lot of my time and
separating me from my peers in locker
rooms and sports does nothing but harm
my development socially and permit
discrimination against kids like me
something which should be unacceptable
if we are truly meant to Live Free or
Die being transgender is not a choice I
made I was born this way and it will
always be who I am the only choice I've
made is to be myself something which is
increasingly hard as laws in the nation
like this pass making our state and
Country an inhospitable place for
transgender people respecting me for who
I am does not cost anyone anything just
ask my friends and teammates at school I
urge you gain respect and vote itl on
hp48 to protect our transgender citizens
sincerely mayel
jacqu thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you Kelly Warner followed by Elmer
mcdono
Elanor morning I'm nervous I've never
testified before um my name is Kelly
Warner I've been a high school teacher
for 24 years I live in exor but I teach
in Maine so I have school break this
week I speak on behalf of the New
Hampshire students and teachers who
cannot miss school to be here today uh
specifically I'd like to read the
testimony of a high school student at
exitor high school um Hana Cass she
submitted her testimony to
you to go to the top
dear members of the House Judiciary
Committee I felt it was important for me
to First Express how to how aggravating
it is to have to be writing this letter
of opposition right now instead of doing
my actual homework but I leave the I
believe that protecting my trans nine
binary and other gender non-conforming
friends is more important and you should
too with that being said please oppose
and vote down HB 148 you see the only
thing I and the other
lgbtqia plus youth around me want is to
live our lives in peace without the
concern of being discriminated against
by our peers let alone by the government
as I see it HB 148 would open the
floodgates to more anti-trans
legislation as it allows classifications
on the basis of biological sex this
means my trans and non-binary friends
have to be worried about where they can
use the restroom and where they can
change before going to gym class do you
understand how absurd that is folks in
support of this bill may tell you that
they are worried about women's safety
with trans people in the women's B
bathroom I'm going to let you in on a
little secret though trans people have
always been in your bathrooms you just
saw them as the women they are and not
as some sort of political scare tactic I
am a cisgender woman meaning the doctors
told my parents I was a girl when I was
born and I've drown grown up into the
young adult woman I am today and guess
what I haven't spent a single second
worrying about if a transwoman or a nonb
non-binary person came into my school's
girls bathroom in fact when I go to the
bathroom everyone usually just Minds
their own business and then leaves the
bathroom in a calm discreet manner no
one pays attention I apologize that's
your time thank you thank
you because you were
we're we're being fair of the people
that did sign up we we are rotating
between supporters and opposition she
submitted her pin card a little later
than most people so we're putting her
towards the end of it but thank you for
asking Ellena mcnano followed by Crystal
bloom
good morning Mr chairman members of the
Judiciary Committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Elanor
MCD I live in exiter and I am opposed to
hb1 148 New Hampshire is a state that
values personal freedom for its citizens
and this legislation is a significant
blow to the freedoms that we hold dear
by attacking people simply because they
are different this discriminatory bill
is government overreach at its worst and
is another example of conservative
cancel culture trying to erase
transgender and gender non-conforming
people in attempt to force us out of
public life this Bill sets the
horrifying precedent of creating a
government so big it demands you drop
your pants for genital inspections a
government that is so invasive it
demands blood draws and chromosomal
tests for all people to dictate who can
play sports and use restrooms all to
solve a problem that does not exist this
legislation comes from a place of hatred
and animus towards a group of
law-abiding taxpaying citizens who have
done nothing wrong other than be
misunderstood by a bill sponsor who has
put forth only hypothetical scenarios
where people who pretend to be trans
might commit crimes so why not focus on
those hypothetical criminals instead of
painting us all with the same brush if
people had complaints against from
constituents about any other community
protected by civil rights laws would the
sponsor be targeting those people as
well the legislation is also poorly
conceived as it as it does not define
the term biological sex the sponsor
saying everyone can tell and the bill
ends up erasing intersex people from
legal existence in addition to making
life significantly more difficult for
transgender people the sponsor is
specifically targeting transgender
children in schools with this bills
trans kids are insistent persistent and
consistent about who they are and the
trend of legislating against their
existence is not only disturbing it's
having an adverse impact on their mental
health it's time for these attacks on
them to stop the government has no
business bullying children for being
simply who they are it's time to stop
wasting time on this of this important
body on unnecessary regulations and
instead focus on issues that graned
stators care about my question to
legislators is this what does this have
to do with the price of eggs New
Hampshire should be continue all
citizens live free say no to hate in the
grite state please vote it on this thank
you any questions seeing none thank you
Crystal Bloom followed by Nancy
Berman good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Crystal
Bloom I am a resident of New Hampshire I
was born and raised in New Hampshire and
I live in
francistown um I have a decade of
experience working in human services
with a master of Social Work degree from
the University of New Hampshire with a
focus on global and National policy and
the effects on communities and
individuals I want to highlight you have
my testimony or my written testimony in
front of you um it starts with today's
date and in opposition to HB 148 I just
want to highlight um that sexual
violence and assault in prisons has been
an ongoing issue for the over 20 years
now um this bill does nothing but
exacerbate that
issue I also want to highlight that if
we truly want to protect women and girls
in public then we need to be addressing
the culture of abuse in our society not
sex
discrimination um in closing I would
like to urge the committee to think
critically about how this bill would be
enforced to me it reads as though it
would be a gross invasion of personal
privacy um so thank you again for this
opport Unity to testify against HB 148
and please vote itl any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Nancy Burman followed
by Ty
Thompson hi Me Andy Beerman New
Boston um I've just heard Tes me of
somebody saying this isn't a problem it
is a problem we have in my district a
little girl who's using the boys room um
those boys have no priv privacy when
they're using the urinal not sure why
she feels like she needs to be in there
um there is uh according to Title 9 UM
it allows separation of restroom and
locker room facilities based on sex
section
10633 um a recipient May provide
separate toilet locker room and shower
facilities on the basis of sex but such
facilities provided for students of one
sex shall be comparable to such
facilities provided for students of the
other sex why does that not apply to
school
bathrooms I would also say that um we
can differentiate based on biological
sex uh the appeals courts in different
parts of the country have found that
biological sex separation is allowed
including the 11th Circuit Court of
Appeals in Adams and the 10th Circuit
Court of Appeals in Etsy
sex separated facility facilities are
justified by school's interest in
protecting its students bodily privacy
per New Hampshire school board policy
ACA Title Nine of the education
amendments Act of 1972 as well as RSA
19338 among others the school does not
discriminate based on this on the basis
of sex in its education programs and
activities including employment and
admissions in fact the uh board policy
ACAC was just updated and we uh most
School boards are doing emergency
adaptations of this new
policy um like most forms of sexual
harassment there's an unhealthy power
differential between schools and the
students who are pressured to share
private facilities in this way many
students are exceedingly uncomfortable
but at this young age students would
rather endure the sexual harassment than
risk the harassment and stigma that
comes with going against the authority
of their school on this issue the little
boys at the school district that I am do
not use the bathroom that's your time
okay thank you any
questions seeing none thank you Ty
Thompson followed by lay off
Frank thank you for the opportunity to
speak to the committee today I'd like to
just do a little bit of a a real time
invitation about perception and ask you
to just register who you perceive me to
be in this moment um and if that changes
if I take off my mask because I think
this legislation actually really is
about perception uh and the perception
of individuals identity uh as they move
through the
world so I am Ty Thompson I am a
transmasculine non-binary person my
pronouns are they them I live in
Nottingham New Hampshire I'm opposed to
this legislation this is legislation
that introduces the opportunity to
discriminate based on perception and
what we've heard in earlier uh
introduction of the bill is that it is
up to your discretion as the state or a
business owner or whomever to choose
whether or not you choose to enforce um
discrimination in this way and deny
access to restrooms by by saying that
you must enter the space that aligns
with your assigned sex at Birth so I
have always been a more masculine
presenting person even prior to Medical
transition as part of my journey in this
world uh throughout my life as my
younger self entering women's restroom
spaces I have been yelled at threatened
gotten the weird looks and the strange
comments and the
surprise I was
present last week at the Senate hearing
for this same bill and the senator who
introduced the bill when asked how would
we how would we regulate this and how
would we force it his response was to
say I don't know that's not my job but
if it was my daughter I would enforce it
this is not a Veiled Threat this is a
direct threat and what it is doing is
really fear-mongering and continue to
like justify this type of fearful
response to vulnerable vulnerable
members of our communities uh and it's
not just and it's going to create more
problems I apologize but that's your
time yeah
question representative McFarland could
you could you stay for one question yes
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony so I I appreciate your
testimony uh as regards somebody having
a a casual encounter with you and trying
to form an understanding of of what you
may be and what you may not be if you
understand the bill to in large part be
focused on fac facilities in schools and
in uh prisons and other detention
facilities nature of the relationship
with the individuals is a longlasting
one could you explain uh why it
is a complicated matter in that
circumstance I think bills like this are
really the tip of the iceberg for
continued legislation ongoing that
perpetuates uh rights and freedoms of
individuals who are transgender
individuals I think that this
legislation has broader implication
besides just what happens in schools and
what happens in prisons it's really
about being able to discriminate and say
that people can only use restrooms
changing spaces locker rooms Etc across
all areas of our New Hampshire
life any other questions seeing none
thank
you Leo Frank followed by actually I'm
going to have a recess this after this
speaker thank you members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is leor
Frank I'm a resident of Portsmith W 2 uh
and I also uh work at a high school uh
I'm also a transgender man I am proud to
have transitioned in New Hampshire at
New Hampshire clinics uh and I'm
testifying against HB 148 today in my
experience transgender people in general
and transgender youth in particular are
not a threat to public spaces like
bathrooms or locker rooms are not a
threat to other prisoners while
incarcerated and are not a threat to
fairness in sports in fact transgender
transgender people especially
transgender women and girls are at far
higher risk of violence and sexual
violence in these spaces than there
isgender counterparts New Hampshire has
good law on the books protecting trans
people and there is no reason to peel
back these protections and that includes
the school sports issue the overblown
concerns being presented today present
this issue as entirely black and white
but there have absolutely been effective
regulations used by athletic
associations from youth to professional
leagues that effectively regulate trans
participation in sports often in
collaboration with athletes Healthcare
Providers and it is entirely possible to
ensure fairness and safety without
excluding trans people from Sports
entirely I find the impulse to
immediately ban to be very troubling gr
transgender granite Staters deserve the
same options for recreation and healthy
activity as everyone else these skills
are built during childhood and if you
take away these opportunities these will
create poor health outcomes in the
future I urge you to oppose HB 148 and
all anti-trans legislation because there
are real issues facing the people of New
Hampshire that they want action on and
this is a waste of time thank you any
questions at all saying nothing thank
you I'm going to call On Em
Brock
Brock good morning thank you for letting
me speak
I here today as a mother asking you to
vote no on HP 148 I'm a proud mother of
two kind smart artistic young adults one
who is
transgender I wish I didn't have to be
here today but my family is under
attack many politicians have decided
that my child is a predator that does
not deserve equal rights this is wrong
and goes against everything that New
Hampshire is supposed to stand for in
the self-proclaimed Live Free or Die
State according to the am American
Psychiatric association the term
transgender refers to a person whose sex
assigned at Birth I.E the sex assigned
at Birth usually based on external
genitalia does not align their J
identity with their gener identity I.E
one psychological sense of their gender
being transgender does not make you a
Peeping Tom being transgender does not
make you a pedophile being transgender
does not make you a predator the concern
I hear referenced without evidence is
that men will pretend that they are
transgender to gain access to bathrooms
and locker rooms to pray on women if
anyone a woman a man or a transgender
woman or a transgender man is behaving
in a predatory way we have other
harassment privacy and sexual assault
laws that can remove anyone acting
inappropriately there's no logic to the
thought that transgender people's rights
should be taken away just in case s
gender men try to access women's
bathrooms discrimination is not to be
taken lightly and should not be allowed
just in case my daughter is a New
Hampshire citizen who deserves to live
freely just as her brother does my
family is not a woke agenda we are real
people that suffer the real consequences
of the hateful rhetoric being pushed by
some
politicians at this point I just wish
the politians politicians would leave us
alone I apologize but that's your
time I asked you that I submitted a
paper um including a speech that my
daughter wrote last year regarding
suicide among transgender youth I urge
you to please read it thank you any
questions at all seeing none thank you
okay at this point I'm going to recess
the hearing on House Bill 148 so that I
can open up the hearing on House Bill
584 and I'm going to recess that hearing
to March 12th at 9:30 a.m. so if you're
here for house Bill 584 that has been
recessed to March 12th at 9:30
a.m. all right I'm going to reopen the
hearing on House Bill 148 and recognize
Aurora
werby followed by Cedar Pleasant
good morning honorable members of the
Judiciary Committee and members of the
public my name is Miss Arora Weatherby I
live in Derry New Hampshire half for my
entire life um some of you may May
recognize me from my testimony a few
weeks ago against uh the now withdrawn
House Bill
476 frankly I'm disappointed in the
state's legislature that I felt it
necessary to testify against two P Bill
proposals in such a short period of time
given the uh rather short um two-minute
limit I'm going to get right to the
point um how will this provision be
enforced will we be checking genitals
the thought of having everyone's
genitals checked at the bathroom door
seems unappealing to say the least if we
didn't check genitals then how would we
Define biological sex would we re would
we require every New Hampshire citizen
to get a chromosome test who would pay
for those how would the state deal with
chromosomal differences such as Klein
felters and Turners would we require
people to amend their birth certificates
and documents if testing revealed a
surprise that was previously
unknown I would also like to focus on uh
the provision that allows um trans
people to be housed in the um
Correctional Facilities of their assign
sex at Birth Studies have shown that
trans women uh when housed in men's
prisons have incredibly High rates of
prison rape whether intended or not this
bill if passed will result in transwoman
convicts being brutally raped by male
inmates as a transwoman myself it feels
as if the sponsors and supporters of
this bill have looked me directly in the
eyes and said I do not care if you get
raped members of the committee if you
vote for this bill all subsequent prison
rapes just interrupt you for a second
let's not apply motives to other
Representatives please uh that wasn't
that was not the intent I'm just
expressing my own feelings about the
bill um as a final point I take issue
with the wording of biological sex as
mentioned earlier and I would like to
close uh by saying that I am sad to see
New Hampshire being so affected by
national political Trends our state has
always prided itself in preserving
individual Freedom not freedom for big
groups I plead with the committee
preserve what makes New Hampshire time
Live Free or Die death is not the worst
of evils give this state liberty or give
it
death Cedar
Pleasant followed by Elizabeth
Richards Dear honorable members of the
Judiciary Comm my name is Cedar Pleasant
I'm a Manchester
resident it's been pretty well
documented with the previous speakers
that this bill does nothing to create
safety it's also been said that how are
we going to enforce it and I want to
address that in a different
way the bill is directly directed at
trans population the sponsors and
proponents of the bill are not afraid of
women entering a men's room they are
clearly afraid of men entering a woman's
room it was specific specifically
mentioned by the sponsor today Let's
ignore the cruelty for a moment of not
acknowledging that trans women are
women let's focus through the lens of
the sponsors speaking this
morning that the in a way that can be
understood that way the only thing
stopping men from walking into a woman's
restroom is a
door so this isn't about fear of trans
women it's about fear of men
of which most of the sponsors of this
bill are or are
they how do we actually know that
multiple sponsors of this bill are
men how will it be enforced and make no
mistake cisgendered people will be
subjected to the same treatments in
verifying gender as transgender people
are specifically addressing the worry
about sports with transgender people
there are already Men playing women's
sports there are already women playing
men's sports what keeps you from knowing
it is you're making it so unsafe for
people to say it so they have always
been women and they have always been
men if you actually are interested in
safety the bill is useless in helping it
the Amer as as previously mentioned the
American acad of Pediatrics in 2019 I
apologize but that's your time thank you
please oppose this bill strongly any
questions seeing none thank you
Elizabeth
Richards followed by Sam
Hawkins good morning uh thank you so
much for hearing my testimony my name is
Elizabeth Richards I'm a resident of
Pembrook New Hampshire and I'm here
today in opposition to House Bill 148 I
am not transgender like so many of the
people you've heard from today my
children are not trans my spouse isn't
trans there's no one in my family who's
trans uh and for a moment when I Was
preparing to come today I thought that
maybe that made my testimony less valid
I don't have a personal story to share
but I don't need a personal connection
to know that this is wrong when you hear
a community who is at greater risk for
violence telling you this puts us at
risk we have an obligation to listen and
to act
trans people have always been here they
will always be here they are a part of
our community they are our neighbors and
our friends and our loved ones and we
have an obligation to listen to their
stories and to act in their best
interests I want to live in a state and
in a community where all people can
Thrive and feel safe and welcome this
bill does not do that we have
established law that says that all
people are safe and welcome here I don't
understand it is absolutely confounding
to me why we are even revisiting this
please please vote in opposition to this
bill listen to the constituents who have
come um as I said this has no personal
bearing on my life and I still took a
day off work to to be here people feel
very passionately about this and have
turned out to tell you how they feel uh
it's been overwhelming today to listen
to the testimony I hope it has been for
you as well and that you'll vote in
opposition to this Bill thank
you Sam Hawkins followed by uh John H is
it
Hopkins you'll be next good morning
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is Sam Hawkins I'm representing
Nami New Hampshire in opposition to
House Bill 148 as an organization
committed to promoting the mental
Wellness of every Granite ster Nami New
Hampshire is deeply concerned by the
harmful impacts of stigma and
discrimination on Mental Health as such
we are firm in our opposition to any
policies that further stigma and enable
discrimination and this bill does just
that in the compelling State interest
established in the Bill's text it
furthers damaging stigma and in its
policies it will expose Granite Staters
to discrimination in their communities
in workplace in involuntary treatment in
places where people choose to be but
also in places places where people have
no choice in being this will have a
chilling effect not only on our trans
and non-binary community members but
also their families their loved ones and
the communities they've found inform
formed in this state for that reason
Nami New Hampshire urges the committee
to vote itl on houseb 148 and any
similar policies that come before the
committee any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Reverend John
Hopkins followed by Will
Oliver good morning thank you for uh
being here and for having me testify I'm
Pastor Jonathan Hopkins I'm the pastor
of Concordia Lutheran Church here in
conquered New Hampshire and I oppose
this bill as a father as of a trans
child who has to walk through this world
every
day uh in fear of being bullied and
discriminated against I speak against it
as a CI of and someone who grew up in
New Hampshire and loves this state I
unfortunately I've told my child who now
goes to college in Massachusetts that
they probably can never live in New
Hampshire again it will be unsafe for
them to do
so um and I oppose it as a pastor and
that's really other people have spoken
more eloquently about uh being a parent
and being a citizen but as a
pastor I want you to know that in the
Old Testament there are actually eight
genders
in the original Hebrew that our given
voice in in that text there's nothing in
Jesus words that would have us
discriminate against trans folks the and
so and even if there was let's just
let's just assume that the biblical
witness was clear that we should
discriminate somehow against trans folks
even if that was that would be usurped
by the Commandment that we all follow
which is to love your neighbor as
yourself and you've heard much testimony
today
eloquently from people of your state
begging you and I am begging you to love
their children to care for their
children enough not to discriminate
against them I'm asking you to not
discriminate against people in my
congregation who try to live a life of
love and care and be good citizens and
you are making it more hard by this by
passing laws like this you have
demonized as other people have said
demonize people for cheap political
points to win elections and instead of
loving and caring for all the citizens
that you serve refra from applying
motive to the bill please well take it
for what it's worth that's your time
okay thank you asking your pastor to
speak for two minutes is
difficult you have a question
representative Horgan um I was well I
was just saying if would you find if you
found that what your family went through
was probably very difficult but not as
difficult as it would have been if your
uh child had not transitioned to be who
they really are is that a fair statement
that no I wouldn't say that I would say
that our family has been greatly blessed
because my child struggled their whole
life
to thank you find out who they are and
once they did I have to say my kid was
on like eight different meds once they
transitioned they are only on one men
and that's testosterone Oh thanks thank
cool thanks
thank you thank you will Oliver oh I'm
sorry
yes here I I have a just a very quick
question for you it for you it's my
understanding that one of the things
that's very important in the New
Hampshire legislature is that we have
hearings on every bill and we do not
assume that um the members of the
committee are in support or in
opposition we are here today to hear
from the public and to help
inform um our views to give us more
information so am I am I incorrect In in
assuming no in stating not just assuming
that no one should assume that they know
how any member of this committee will
eventually vote Yes you are absolutely
correct thank
you will
Oliver followed by is it Zoe Hill you'll
be
next good morning chair and members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to speak my name is Will Oliver I am a
concerned New Hampshire resident and a
non-binary person I proudly live and
work in the white mountain region
serving visitors to this great state I'm
testifying today because I would be
horrified to ask one of my trans friends
to use the wrong bathroom or
facility I think it is appalling that
Representatives who sit in our
government so lack a basic understanding
of trans people that they would even
suggest such a law if there is one thing
that we can all learn from the queer
movement it's that we need to believe
people when they tell us who they are if
you need science to back that up I say
to this bill sponsors knock yourself out
check out the recommendations from the
APA the AMA you name it I and so many
other Americans are sick of hearing
trans people scapegoated when they are
doing nothing wrong if their concerns
about safety or about privacy great
there are already other laws in place
for that but those concerns give
lawmakers no right to discriminate
against people on the basis of gender
identity a protection that is literally
specified by the law that this bill aims
to amend policing people's gender as
they enter the bathroom leads to a
slippery slope of body inspections and
potentially worse for everyone and those
are proposals we've heard suggested
elsewhere in our country country if we
are so concerned about the safety of our
residents if we are so concerned about
women and children then why don't we
look at the group who is most
responsible for violence against them
both sexual and physical that's right
cisgender men an overwhelming majority
in some cases up to 94% of perpetrators
if we are so concerned about the safety
of women and children then why don't we
follow the statistics instead of
obsessing over imaginary crimes
committed by trans
people the most dangerous person to
women and children in the state of New
Hampshire is a man that they know and I
think that this fact is exactly what
bills like this hope to distract
from trans people are beautiful powerful
wonderful brave people they deserve so
much more than this our friends
neighbors co-workers and family members
that's your time they deserve so much
more than this I also wanted to submit
one piece of evidence um a proponent of
this bill earlier mentioned a study uh
claiming that trans women retain a quote
male pattern of criminality but I can
sub evidence from that stud's author
debunking that Mis interpretation for
women who were convicted of crimes after
1989 they found no such pattern thank
you I can email
that Zoe
Hill followed
by Boyd
hagy and I apologize if I don't get your
name correct a lot of names here goe
good morning Representatives uh my name
is Zoe Hill I'm a resident of Lebanon
and and I am here to oppose HB um
148 this bill specifically targets a
very small group of people in the
granite state it will cause physical and
psychological
harm it is against the Live Free or Die
way so just vote inexpedient to
legislate on this bill any questions
seeing none thank you
nice
and Boyd
hegerty followed by Lisa
Balwin hi my name is Boyd hegerty I live
in Ry New Hampshire District 24 I'm the
father of a transgender woman I oppose
HB
148 my daughter spoke before this
committee when she was 12 years old
she spoke in front of the entire house
when she was 13 years old she showed
amazing courage now she is
terrified in terms of bathrooms tell me
please what is her choice she is
terrified of being forced to use a men's
bathroom and thus being assaulted
potentially by men if she uses a women's
bathroom she is terrified of violating
this proposed law and being put in jail
with men also
proposed as my daughter has extensively
researched and point out it's
essentially a sentence for abuse and
possible death 1.7% of the population is
interex 1.6 is
transgender that's approximately 23,000
Granite sters each this is a reality
only two Sexes not only two Sexes not
only two genders stop terrifying
transgender and interex people stop
terrifying my daughter HB 148 is
Terrorism thank
you thank you any
questions seeing none Thank you Lisa
Balwin Lisa
Bodwin okay
Amelia
Thompson are you Amelia Thompson thank
you good morning and thank you for
listening my name is Amelia and I'm from
New Market Rockingham County I urge you
to oppose Bill
148 as a cisgender woman born a woman
identified as a woman this bill does not
keep me any safer when I use public
restrooms and trust me I have a lot of
experience with public restrooms being
an outdoor worker I have to use them all
day long no man has ever tried to get in
there to hurt me however some male
legislators think that they can surveil
me in the restroom and that's okay it's
not okay and what else is not okay is
surveillance of my trans family members
and
friends I have a transwoman family
member who is also afraid like was
previously mentioned that if she's
forced to use the women's restroom
against this law because she doesn't
want to be assaulted in the men's
restroom that she'll have to go to Men's
prison or men but it's terrifying to
people and it needs to stop it doesn't
help anybody this bill but it hurts
everybody through the extra surveillance
possibly extra use of taxpayer money to
like enforce it nobody is helped by this
and everybody is harmed so let's oppose
it table it whatever we have to do to
get rid of this Bill thank you so much
for listening to me any questions and
everyone else in this
room okay seeing no questions thank you
thank you very much Billy
strong followed by Laura is it brigata
briia
C good morning my name is Billy strong I
was born in New Hampshire I have lived
here the majority of my life and I
currently work full-time as a mechanical
and Robotics engineer in Manchester I
also happen to be a transgender woman
this bill creates a carve out from our
state's discrimination protections
designed specifically to facilitate the
oppression of of gender nonconforming
individuals like myself the text
describes circumstances in which
classification based on biological sex a
term as others have noted which is not
defined in the text of the bill or the
amended statute would be broadly
permitted the justif justification
provided for this classification is
protecting rights and physical safety
privacy rights and physical safety but
this text would permit individuals and
organizations to discriminate based on
personal physiological characteristics
which cannot always be ascertained in
civil interaction
in practice this language will encourage
public confrontations of gender
non-conforming people by private
individuals solely based on our
appearance and social presentation a
practice which would surely threaten our
privacy and safety this would affect
both children and adults and would have
impacts extending far beyond the trans
Community not all visibly gender
non-conforming persons are
transgender a goodfaith effort to
protect the privacy and safety of all
citizens would account for the risks
faced by all citizens including those
who do not conform to stereotypical
gender roles and
presentations this bill is written from
a perspective which views gender
non-conforming people like me as
intrinsically threatening or harmful by
omitting explicit mitigations for The
Unique privacy and safety risks
experienced by transgender people this
Bill de prioritizes our safety relative
to the rest of the population on this
basis I oppose the adoption of this text
into law and I encourage the members of
this committee to do the same thank you
for your time any questions seeing none
thank you thank
you Laura
batti followed by
Colleen uh
gadwa Laura brigata Hudson New
Hampshire I came here today because I am
a woman and I am afraid I have been
afraid since the non-discrimination bill
passed in
2018 um I became aware of these isues
many years ago when I was a teenager and
they were published in the
newspaper and it became clear back
around 2003 that wow if if these men
biological men who say they're trans um
assert their rights over women women's
rights are dead letter how can we go
into a bathroom and and not be afraid of
seeing a man about not being able to
speak up if something is going wrong
that is the key to women's bathrooms the
idea that women collectively are aware
of what goes on and that we speak up as
soon as something is going wrong that
we're not waiting for somebody to get
raped that we're not waiting for some
man to commit a sex act that we're not
wondering if some man is in this
bathroom for a sexual
thrill
ick how can we tell our daughters that
it's okay in this state to go and change
their mentor products I would have loved
to have been either a girl scout leader
or something similar I remember my girl
scout leader one of them being able to
tell some man who was hanging around
being threatening to to go away
and women as confident as they may be as
spunky as they may be can only have
those confrontations to say hey you're
hanging around we've got a bunch of Girl
Scouts here please please back away
please go away um if if they can call
the police if the law is on our side
without the law
um I I always am wondering when I leave
that well am I going to have a safe
bathroom and most of the time I conclude
it's not worth it um I've known some of
that is your time thank you thank you I
apologize any questions thank
you Colleen
gadwa followed by Avery
Roy thank you members of the committee
I'm reading testimony from a person who
could not be here today Colleen gadwa
this bill which seeks to classify
individuals based on biological sex and
laboratory facilities locker rooms
sporting competitions and detention
facilities is a harmful and
discriminatory proposal that undermines
the dignity safety and rights of
transgender and gender non-conforming
individuals it perpetuates exclusion
Fosters inequality and ignores the lived
experiences of those who do not conform
to rigid binary gender Norms by
mandating such classifications this bill
not only violates the principles of
fairness and inclusivity but also puts
vulnerable individuals at risk of
harassment discrimination and violence
transgender people deserve the same
rights and protections as everyone else
including the right to access public
spaces participate in sports and be
treated with respect and detention
facilities this bill sends a damaging
message that their identities are
invalid and Unworthy of recognition this
legislation is unnecessary and divisive
there is no evidence to suggest that
inclusive policies pose a threat to
Public Safety or fairness in sports in
fact inclusive environments benefit
Everyone by fostering understanding
respect and equality this bill instead
seeks to solve a problem that does not
exist while creating real harm for
transgender individuals and their
families we must stand against this bill
in any legislation that seeks to
marginalize dehumanize People based on
their gender identity our society should
strive to protect and uplift all its
members not enact policies that exclude
and discriminate I urge lawmakers to
reject this bill and instead focus on
creating policies that promote equality
dignity and justice for everyone thank
you thank you Avery
Roy followed by Christine Hughes
thank you committee members good morning
my name is Avery I am a transgender
woman I am a resident of New Hampshire I
have lived my whole life in the state of
New Hampshire or I'm resident of
Manchester excuse me I'm here today to
voice my Fierce opposition to HB 148 I
can tell you the legal issues with this
bill that biological sex is a vague and
undefined term both legally and
scientifically neither the text of this
bill nor RSA 34 5A defines this term
leaving it vulnerable to misuse more
importantly adding exceptions to
existing anti-discrimination ordinances
is dangerous and unethical if we
legalize discrimination based on sex and
gender how does this not open legal
Pathways to other discrimination based
on other factors in existing
anti-discrimination ordinances it is
unacceptable to carve out holes and
legal protections for any granite stator
I can also give you my personal issues
with this bill that it emboldens and
encourages big against many people
including but not limited to women the
lgbtq community and the trans people in
particular this vague statute will
embolden those who wish to discriminate
and confront people they view as others
something we experience quite enough of
already whether it's passers by who
shouted slays at me or shouted slays at
my community as we mourned our dead on
the steps of the capital whether it's my
coworker who when I confided my trans
identity to him repeatedly made
disgusting comments and told me that he
would rape me
this bill enables this harassment and
violence and prevents legal recourse for
those affected it makes it acceptable to
Target anyone deemed not man or woman
enough against an arbitrary standard of
acceptability HB 148 is discriminatory
in its intent and flawed in its text I
strongly oppose this bill and I urge you
to do the same thank you any questions
seeing none thank you and paper copies
for y Christine Hughes followed by
Julian l
okay my name is Christine Hughes and I'm
here to oppose HB
148 I've raised a transgender daughter
I've been here to testify a few times
over the last many
years my daughter knew who she was when
she was 5 years old and her dad who
spoke earlier and I educated ourselves
and supported our child our community in
Durham New Hampshire made way for her to
develop into the strong young woman that
she is today but it wasn't always easy
for her we had one experience at a local
me movie theater when she went into the
bathroom that matched her gender marker
on her birth certificate a large man
approached me to say ma'am your daughter
was using the wrong bathroom this was
when she was probably 8 years old
imagine what people would say if she
started using the men's bathroom at 19 I
want to say I think she looks a little
bit like dual Lipa the famous talented
musician another time when she was using
the bathroom that matched her gender
marker on her birth certificate at
school she was stopped by her peers in
the bathroom and they made her pull her
pants down to prove that she had a
penis whose privacy was being protected
in this
instance she was able to play on several
teams throughout her time in the Oyster
River School District and she also
attended a private high school where she
was welcom to compete on the girls'
teams she heard Slanders from marks
being shouted from the sidelines by
students whose privacy was at stake in
this
situation who exactly are they trying to
protect and why really there will always
be exceptions to any rule but there are
many transgender law-abiding active
service members in our community that do
not need to be discriminated against
because they there are people who are
anxious about things they are unwilling
to try and understand
I can guarantee that the transgender
people in our state live most days in a
constant state of fear because of all
the idiots think they know better I
apologize but that's your time okay
please vote no on HB 148 we are very
tired of this thank you thank you
Jillian
leay followed by Sarah Smith
good morning uh my name is Julian Lee
and I live in Hampton
Falls I'm a longtime resident of New
Hampshire and proud to be a citizen of
this Live Free or Die State and I'm also
transgender I have been all my life and
I'm proud of that as well I lead a
transgender adult support group and as a
result I've met and and know hundreds of
transgender
women when I was a kid I didn't know the
word for being trans but now I do and
fortunately now we have reams of
corresponding data about trans people in
today every reputable Medical
Association affirms our our
existence the last time I uh I was here
and testified uh it was eight years ago
on behalf of HB
thankfully that Landmark uh legislation
was passed adding gender identity to
state law and it changed my life in that
of thousands of New Hampshire
residents in the most positive ways
imaginable sadly now eight years later
we're back here again debating trans
rights and whether people like me can
still be
trusted to use a public bathroom that
corresponds to who we really
are fortunately we now have eight years
of
data to prove that we can be a that we
can be trusted that we're
not uh a threat to
anyone I apologize but that's your
time
okay so I would urge the committee
to strongly reject this discriminatory
legislation thank you thank
you Sarah
Smith followed by is it Naomi lmore
good morning my name is Sarah Smith uh
live in pimbrook New Hampshire and I'm
here opposed to HP 148 um for for many
of the reasons that have already been
said today I which I think are show that
it is inherently
discriminatory and uh
I believe that no human being or a class
of people are illegal or inherently
criminal um so I have a few points I
agreed with a lot of what was said
before but um I I I would like to point
out that contrary to what this law
purports women's bathrooms and locker
rooms have privacy features that make
the intended use private as common
practice for single stall bathrooms to
be non-gendered so we know the usage
itself is not a concern to the public
all of the women's locker rooms I have
been in have private changing stalls um
so this this is a to me is is a nonissue
um I agree again that the illegal use of
the facilities for harassment
intimidation or assault is clearly
against the law and all are pro are
innocent until proven
guilty but oh the one point I thing that
hasn't been spoken about here is the
effect that this law has on other people
um so these restrictions don't always
only affect the trans people but their
loved ones friends colleagues work
participation if my trans wife is not
allowed to use the toilet in a place for
instance a restaurant I won't go there
either nor will other friends spor teens
or recreational skiers or people
attending conferences or religious
gatherings won't even come to the state
if people want a North Country
experience they'll visit Maine or
Vermont instead so now what we're
talking about this affecting everyone
and and not just affecting people in
that's your time thank you very much for
your
time Naomi lmore followed by Sarah King
uh hi my name is Naomi lmore I'm a
resident of Dover New Hampshire and I'm
here to speak in opposition to House
Bill 148 classifying one based on
biological sex for the purpose of
entering them into facilities non-
congruent with their identity will only
drastically increase the chance that
this already atrisk demographic will
face sexual violence and discrimination
which RSA
354a specifically for protects against
consider the fact that hormone
replacement therapy directly Alters
one's appearance in the following ways
for trans women development of breaths
hips and redistribution of body mass in
a way which directly parallels the
female biology imagine the danger
someone with these characteristic spaces
in an environment such as a male
prisoner shelter passing this bill will
only lead to rape assault and
discrimination against anyone placed in
these or similar situations which RSA
354 protects against uh furthering that
point statistics recorded by the FBI
concluded that in 2023 over 2,800 hate
crimes were recorded against people in
the lgbtq plus Community almost one in4
of the overall total and over 500 of
these were confirmed to be gender
identity motivated the myth that trans
people are predators is a misinformation
campaign and I would like to challenge
anyone supporting this bill to prove
that otherwise in regards to Athletics
and sports the purpose of this bill is
touted as secur as securing safety and
privacy which is outside of the scope of
competing in sports it's a blatant
attempt to piggy back off of the
executive order that was signed and it
simply as a means to push as much
litigation as quickly and lazily as
possible excuse me as possible due to
all of the above I find House Bill 148
to be mired in hipocracy it states to
protect privacy and physical safety of
all but only serves the place of
minority with valid legal rights
unfairly into dangerous environments
that are not fitting with the
anti-discrimination laws the very Bill
seeks to attempt to amend in doing this
it directly contradicts itself and RSA
354 when it states New Hampshire's
fundamental commitment to treat all
persons without discrimination and
respect perfect that's your time cool um
I just want to say if you guys are
representing the people please listen to
the people thank
you Sarah King followed by Scott Phyllis
hello my name is Sarah King I'm from
Derry New Hampshire I'm here to voice my
opposition to HB 148 as a history
student at brandise University I would
like to highlight a couple of Parallels
for you the first lgbtqia plus affirming
sexual Research Institute in the world
was in Germany this Clinic's purpose was
to educate the public on sexuality and
gender identity in a way that affirmed
lgbtqia plus people it had Library a
museum and counseling that Illustrated
the diversity of human gender and
sexuality throughout history and culture
they were one of the only places that
would hope openly hire trans people they
provided gender affirming care and
surgeries now on May 6th
1933 this institute was burned down by
the Nazi party they then proceeded to
forcibly d-transition strip the rights
of imprison and murder the trans
citizens of Germany alongside thousands
of other queer
individuals history has shown us what
happens when a political groups start
scapegoating others to gain power what
happened in Germany between 1933 and
1945 and that stat phenomena is
happening right now in our country this
bill is intended to scare and divide us
to allow fearmongers to push a group of
people out of public life to classify
and force them into hiding for political
gain and I don't mean to only draw the
parallel to how they treated transgender
people let me be absolutely clear this
sentiment this bill reflects exactly the
Nazi Central ideology of a return to
cultural values which resulted in the
deaths of millions of Jewish people
political dissenters Romani disabled
people and all others who did not fit
their standard in concentration camps
there's a powerful poetic form which has
been circulating the internet as of late
coined by Martin Neer regarding his
guilt about passivity during the Nazi
regime it reads first they came for a
group and I did not speak out because I
was not of that group then they came for
and it continues until it reaches the
point of and then they came for me and
there was no one left to speak for me
thank
you that's your time thank
you Scott
Phyllis followed by David
Trumble good morning honorable
representatives of the house Judiciary
Committee and thank you for listening to
these testimonies today my name is Scott
files I have been a resident of do since
my graduation from UNH in 2016
I'm a loving uncle brother and son and a
good employee of a large New Hampshire
company I'm also a transgender man I
come before you today to voice my
opposition of House Bill 148 looking at
me today do you really think it is
appropriate for me to use a women's
restroom if this bill is passed I could
be forced to do so I can imagine
scenarios of confused and uncomfortable
women and children questioning my
presence in a women's room why is that
man in here would be irrelevant and
innocent question as I am a man I do not
see how this could be construed as
protecting my own or others privacy
rights or physical safety notably my
presence in a men's room has never been
questioned or been an issue in the years
since my transition I know that I am
very lucky as a trans man I pass very
well walking down the street people
cannot tell that the gender I identify
as does not align with the sex I was
assigned at Birth others do not have it
so easy many trans non-binary and
intersex folk face hatred and danger
just by leaving their houses each day
bills like hp48 would allow
discrimination based on gender and sex
but only when they do not align gender
and sex do not have to align if they did
we would only have one word for both IC
bills and policies like HB 148 is
snowballs which if allowed to roll will
allow for the passage of more extreme
more harmful and more hateful policies
policies that would endanger your
constituent's health and well-being
please stop this before it starts please
vote no on
hp48 thank you thank you thank
you at this point I'm going to recess
the hearing on House Bill 148 and open
the hearing on House Bill 580 and I'm
going to recess that hearing to March
12th at 10:15 a.m. so if you're here to
speak on House Bill 580 that has been
recessed to March 12th at 10:15
a.m. I'm going to open reopen the
hearing on House Bill 148 and recognize
David Trumble
after David will be Drew
Carson thank you Mr chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble I'm from the town of wear and I
oppose this bill the prime sponsor said
that this bill is good because it
doesn't require discrimination it allows
reasonable latitude but what the bill
really does it sets up a legal framework
that would permit any organization in
this state public or private to
discriminate the state's job is not to
take away civil rights but to protect
civil rights and you can only take away
civil rights if you have compelling
evidence that it is necessary and that
there is no less restrictive alternative
the law also serves the purpose to
educate the public if we keep the 2018
law in effect we are telling the people
of the state that transgender people are
welcome here that they have much to
offer and they we believe in them and if
you have listened to the testimony today
in all of the past hearing you'll know
that the transgender people have spoke
with decency respect and intelligence
they are valuable members of our society
we have nothing to fear from them
however if you pass this bill you're
telling the people of our state that
there are two classes of citizens in
this state two sets of civil rights and
that discrimination is acceptable but
what about the Civil Rights of a person
who wants to go to a public hearing and
can't use a bathroom you are taking away
their free association and their free
speech what if they want to be a
legislator how could they be here all
day if they could never use a bathroom
what about the Civil Rights of somebody
who's confined to a male institution
when they are a transgender female and
the mental health problems associated is
really how Society treats them that
would be counter to their treatment what
about the Civil Rights of a transgender
woman who was sent to a male's prison
and has a 60% rate of being raped what
about their civil rights what about the
rights of children who just want to
compete in sports there are other ways
you can solve this problem there are
less restrictive Alternatives you can
have non-gender specific bathrooms you
could have different policies than there
are many as been mentioned in sports
there are less restrictive Alternatives
there is no compelling State interest
here it's your job to protect our civil
rights I apologize that's your time
thank you sir thank
you drew
Carson followed by Lynn
lipet good
morning my name is Drew Carson um I live
in Dover now but I was born and
conquered and grew up in
Chichester I went to St John's and
Bishop Brady and survived 12 years of
Catholic
school after a brief uh time in Maine
for college and grad school in Vermont I
came back to New Hampshire to live and
to work and I'm a transgender man I'm
here to strongly oppose House Bill
148 I knew that I was transgender from
approximately age five and that is
because gender identity lives in our
brains and so that is how we all know
what our gender is whether you're a
transgender or not transgender and you
cannot tell what is in someone else's
brain simply by looking at them just
like you can't tell what someone's
genitals are when they are in public and
they are covered up and we should not
even be striving to know this
information about other people about
other
strangers and that is what this bill is
about it's about strangers is looking at
someone else and thinking they know
better what our gender identity and what
our genitals
are and it's ironic that it's always
cisgendered heterosexual people who are
obsessed with what other people's
identity and genitals look
like transgender people are not
criminals there's no evidence that we
are causing any issues in the bathrooms
or in locker rooms in fact we are much
more likely to be the victims in
bathrooms and locker
rooms last week and again
today someone testified about little
boys using the boys's bathroom at school
and being concerned because someone that
they perceived to be a little girl was
in there when in fact that was a
transgender
boy and I left after hearing that last
week just thinking wouldn't it be nice
if instead the parents message to their
children was I apologize but that's your
time okay thank you thank
you Lynn lipet followed by Leia
Peters good morning committee members
and chairperson um I'm Lyn lipid a
resident of Milford and I have
transgendered family and friends who are
at risk of being harmed if this bill is
passed this bill removed freedoms and
inflicts harm on a vulnerable group of
people that have been protected by New
Hampshire's anti-discrimination laws for
years based on the due diligence of
Prior legislators and the support of the
majority of New Hampshire
citizens the fear that an individual
might cause harm is not a reason to deny
a group of people their freedom and
liberty girls and women can protect
their privacy by using single stalls and
changing areas in bathrooms and locker
rooms it seems the real issue is that
some people are simply uncomfortable
with the idea of using the same
facilities as someone of the same gender
who may not have the same body parts
that they
do but how will they know this whose
privacy is being violated to find out
it's not possible to know someone's sex
assigned at Birth by how they look this
bill encourages anyone to violate the
privacy of anyone else because they feel
uncomfortable this is not a case of
protecting equal concerns it is Comfort
versus safety the result of passing HB
148 will be to put the majority of
transgender and non-binary People In
Harm's Way in order for a few people to
feel more
comfortable there is no way to enforce
this bill without an invasion of privacy
the very thing this bill wants to
curtail this bill allows anyone to
legitimately question someone's sex at
Birth based on what they look like this
power can be used to harass and
intimidate cisgendered people as well as
transgendered and non-binary people
legislation limiting participation in
sports based on sex assigned at Birth is
not right or the best mechanism to
ensure girls and women can safely
participate in sports funding for proper
coaching equipment and supervision for
sports will have a much greater impact
for these reasons I oppose HB 148 and
any similar bill and I urge you and
implore you to please oppose this bill
ored itl do have a question for you you
checked off that you support the bill is
that incorrect it's oppose oh I oppose
it oh I'm sorry that's all right we just
want to make sure we have it right for
the record thank you for corre thank
you Leia
Pedas followed by Fiona Violet paos
paos all
righty good morning my name is Leah
Peters I am a citizen and voter from
dairy and I'll be speaking against the
op option of HP 148 I was born I'm just
having trouble hearing you can you pull
the mic a little closer please okay
thank you yes that's
great okay I was um born and raised in
New Hampshire and I've lived here most
of my life I'm an Air Force veteran and
who served during the Cold War I'm a
medical professional and have worked in
hospitals for 43 years I should mention
that before I joined the military i'
during the Reagan recession I had also
been a history Mak major at Keen State
College I'm here to point out the
irrationalities inherent in the proposed
legislation however to do that I want to
give some historical
background transgender people are not
new they have existed throughout history
in all culture countries cultures and
soci socioeconomic classes a few
examples are the winkey and two spirit
of Native American cultures the muks of
Mexico the Maho of a
theaa of Samoa and the Hijra of India
there is also a Roman Emperor El gabis
that many historians today believe was a
transgender
woman there have been many transgender
people documented in US history as well
the first Clinic to offer gender
affirming care for trender people opened
in
199 by Dr Magnus hersfield of in Berlin
Germany you may have seen the movie the
Danish girl which was about Lily elb who
was a patient at that clinic the Nazis
rans sacked that clinic shortly after
they came to power in
1933 that famous photo you've probably
seen of Nazis burning books was taken
outside that
clinic okay I apologize that's your time
time that's your time that's two minutes
I guess I'll turn this in
I just wanted to mention that
transgender people other LGBT people are
also put in concentration camps course
to wear the pink triangle I'll turn in
the rest of my stuff here thank you
Fiona Violet
paos followed by Carol
pford that was a quick two minutes
hi my name is Tia Violet pulis I am a
conquered resident and I would like to
just help everyone here draw a quick
parallel between past treatment um
regarding
homosexuality and current treatment
regarding trans people I'd like to share
something about myself is that I was uh
male representing in high school I was
afraid to even tell people I was queer
or bisexual but regardless of these
facts I have been assaulted in boy
locker rooms in high school and I've
been sexually assaulted in a men's
bathroom as an adult and I cannot even
begin to tell you how dangerous it is
and how afraid I am personally to enter
a men's bathroom in my current
presentation much of which is physically
transformed due to HRT and the
medication I take for my transition I
can't just undo it I can take my makeup
off I cannot restore fat deposits in my
body temporarily to make myself look
less
feminine I just really hope that
everyone here who makes a decision on
this bill does so with love in their
hearts and empathy for not just s
gendered women but for me for my people
for queer for Trans folks of the State
of New Hampshire who need your
protection and are in danger if the
right to discriminate is given to the
individuals the business and the
legislation the schools and the prisons
and in the future it is not
safe that's it I don't even need the
full 2 minutes I don't know if that was
2 minutes but that's what I have to
share I have submitted my testimony
online great thank you thank
you Carol Pickford followed by
Katie GES
GES hi yeah um my name is Carol Pickford
I'm from Allenstown and I'm here
opposing this bill as a transgender
individual the propos law threatens my
dignity safety and rights coming out of
the closet um then trying to get to uh
go back into it is a lot like trying to
put toothpaste back in the tube 10 years
ago I made the choice to live my life as
a woman and that choice has had
irreversible consequences including the
shattering of many long-standing
previous relationships in the time since
I have worked hard to gain respect and
acceptance from my peers I I didn't
choose uh my innate physical
characteristics and I can assure you
that it is something that makes me more
comfortable every day than it does
anyone else around me to say that my
presence in the women's washroom somehow
affects the safety of others around me
is denigrating beyond belief while the
bill doesn't use these words
specifically it's clear such language
makes out transgender people such as
myself to be rapists and predators not
only is such an assertion patently false
it's an assault on my dignity and
threatens to to erase that respect which
I have worked so hard to build before
attending law school I wrote magazine
articles covering a variety of
transgender related topics
one such topic I covered in depth was
transgender prison reform under the
Biden Administration and what brought it
about one of the cases I covered was
Raven V polus in Colorado where 160
trans women incarcerated in male prisons
sue the state their assertions included
but were by no means limited to sexual
harassment by prisoners and guards being
raped by prisoners and guards being
forcibly tattooed by male prisoners and
treated as property and more I'm happy
to say that Raven V polus had a good
ending involving the gradual integration
of trans women into women's correctional
facilities but today I stand Here
speaking against a bill proposing to
open the door to doing the opposite
prisons for trans women especially have
historically been a place of violence
and Trauma outside the public eye and
Consciousness putting transgender women
in men's prisons constitutes cruel and
unusual punishment and forces the state
to uh choose between housing them in the
general population where they are
frequently raped or isolating them for
indefinite periods of time uh I
apologize but that's your time uh please
please uh post Bill thank you thank
you Katie
remesh followed by Jennifer
Smith hi I'm Katie Remish I'm from
Hollis and I grew up next door in BO I
am opposed to this bill people will
speak and have spoken about the science
and morality and opposition to this
issue and I will try to appeal to your
hearts to paraphrase a testimony I heard
in support of this bill and Simo bills
here and in the Senate session last week
a boy little boy fifth grade maybe walks
into a school bathroom and discover
someone he had believed to be female in
the boy's bathroom he is uncomfortable
confused and has not encountered this
before so he returns to class and
refuses to use the bathroom for the rest
of the day or any day going forward this
is awful I feel for this child no child
should feel uncomfortable using the
bathroom at school but those are the
feelings and this is the story of every
trans child every day when they cannot
use the bathroom that aligns with their
gender this is every trans kid the boy
in the story was told he could get
permission to use a special bathroom
this was upsetting to him and his
parents rightly so no child should have
to feel negatively singled out but trans
children are often told they have to use
a different or special bathroom in the
school we are parents we want all your
children to be happy why can't everyone
empathize with trans kids this choice
right here choosing between two groups
of people cisgender and trans is the
problem instead look at this situation
as a teachable moment how do you resolve
problems between kids you sit them down
and you talk it out you teach them to
show kindness to one another teach them
about pronouns and non-binary and gender
expression and gender identity so there
is no confusion the fifth grade boy now
knows that trans people exist and they
are normal and they are good he is no
longer on un comfortable in the bathroom
he has learned that it is okay that it
is acceptable and when he encounters the
situation again because he will trans
people are everywhere he won't give it a
second thought open conversations solve
this problem not banss not
ostracization please oppose this Bill
thank you thank you perfect timing thank
you Jennifer Smith followed by posher
Roberts hi Jennifer Smith from penbroke
thank you for taking my testimony um
almost all of what I would say has been
said many times um and I just would
reinforce that I I did send you um email
testimony this morning um I included my
email at the end of it in case you don't
see it up the top for some reason and I
would love to answer questions I am
Christian and I am a medical doctor and
both of those things are important to me
um and I just listening to that right
now I want to talk about the fact that
when I was first in kindergarten some
older boys thought I didn't belong in
the bathroom and I messed myself for a
while after that because I didn't think
I should be going there for the next 40
years I worked hard at acting the part
and I did a pretty successful job and
you know I thought when puberty hit I'd
be fine you know I'd turn into a guy and
I'd be happy with it I never was and um
by the time I was in my mid-40s and
things had not been going well I got
some counseling and I began to think
about things and I got a long way along
and then I was in the midst because I
love scripture reading Matthew from
front to back and discovered that there
really not is not only anything against
there being more than one gender in the
gospel but Jesus actually talks about
people who were born Unix and people who
chose to be Unix for the sake of the
kingdom of
God and that really hit me hard and said
yeah this transition stuff is real and I
need to do it and I have been much
happier as anybody can attest since that
time and um in the last several years
I've been back to playing tennis and uh
I play on a woman's team and I assure
you I am not the strongest the fastest I
apologize but that's your time limit
okay and I be happy to answer questions
about any of the medical aspects that
have been brought up and um any other
questions you have I have a lot of
experience in a lot of
areas thank
you Asha
Roberts followed by BJ J
Wall hello um honorable members of the
Judiciary Committee I'm posha Roberts
from Wilman New Hampshire and I'm on the
board of 603 equality and I'm speaking
against
hp48 uh there is a moral panic in this
country around transgender people the
idea of this bill
is to return to simpler times to
biological sex the bill does not define
biological sex really so we're
encouraged to use common sense and I
take that to mean
genitals I'm here to remind you that
nature is not so simple or comforting I
was born into a category known as
intersex not exactly male or female at
Birth the truth is it's not genitals
it's not the big cell and the little
cell it's not even xx and XY there is no
easy definition for sex I know many
people who are born with female genitals
but are
XY I know people who carry two DNA types
both XX and XY they absorbed a twin I
know people whose chromosomes are xxy or
XXX or just X I've even met people with
one ovary and one testicle and people
who were born born with
none there are 35 Medical variations or
ways that a baby can be born intersex
like me there's no bright line nature is
wild this isn't woke this is just how
bodies go how babies are born in
response to the challenge of my body I
was put through two difficult surgeries
as a child to conform me to be male they
rebuilt me so I could look the way they
wanted and use a bathroom the way that
they wanted I was a triangular Peg and
they jammed me into a square
hole pretty darn hard this bill is based
on a flawed non-de of biological sex I
apologize about that your time if a bill
is based on easily disproven medical
facts the bill is invalid please vote
itl BJ
wall followed by Kaden Dole
hi my name is BJ wall I live in Sullivan
New Hampshire which is near Keane and I
oppose this bill on so many things but
most of the people who have come before
me have already said them so I'm just
going to keep it very brief I have two
trans grandsons whom I love very much
the older one who is at UNH and will
graduate next year looks like a lot of
the other trans men and he has a full
beard and he's a little Hefty and I
think I think if he goes in the women's
bathroom where he would be required by
this law to do so that the women are
going to get a little upset when they
see him in there and I think if their
husbands are waiting in the hall they're
going to say what are you doing and
maybe pull him aside and maybe hurt him
and I don't want him to get hurt
obviously the other part of this is
sports sports have never been fair and
never will be fair because everybody's
body type is totally different I think
of um the swimmer Michael Phelps who was
not only had a great wingspan and a and
a huge long body but was uh hyper had
hyperextensive joints and double
jointedness he won all the races CU his
body was just better adapted for
swimming than anyone else and most trans
women who have been on HRT
therapy for a few years act more like
women physically than they do like men
um so I think that's an N issue as well
I think it's very dangerous to put trans
women in a Men's
prison I think this bill really needs to
be ited
thanks thank
you Kaden
Dole followed by Eileen sahajan
San uh thank you to the chairperson and
I also want to quickly thank all the
committee members here uh for your
presence today I can't imagine it's easy
to sit here and receive the the passion
and sometimes the anger that we all um
kind of bring sometimes so thank you
very much U my name is Kaden I'm a grad
student at UNH and I've lived back and
forth across the Vermont New Hampshire
border my whole life I'm here today
because I care about the safety of the
women and girls in my community and I
have three younger sisters and I want
them to be safe in the bathroom so I'll
start by asking what bathroom do you
think I belong in would a woman feel
safe if I entered the women's bathroom
do I belong in a woman's restroom no
because I'm a man clearly right I'm not
a woman when I was born the doctor
handed me to my parents and said
congratulations it's a girl 22 years
later after living as the girl I was
born as I started my transition I am
transgender if you want this bill to
pass you want me in a women's restroom
that's what this bill will allow it's
not enforceable to try to figure out who
is Trans in what bathroom uh all women
will be subject to questions simply
because they don't look girly enough do
you want someone checking if your
daughter is in the right
bathroom that uh that makes a bathroom
more dangerous for women and girls
what's going to happen to a mom who's by
herself with a 2-year-old little boy
that little 2-year-old's got to stay
outside the bathroom that's dangerous uh
bathrooms are uncomfortable for all of
us I'm uncomfortable in the bathroom
with you there too um instead of
scapegoating trans people as the source
of that problem let's talk about the
real problem which is that whoever
designed bathrooms was a super villain
they're awful they are uncomfortable um
so let's decide here together to
legislate bathrooms to be built better
rather than to legislate to discriminate
against trans people with that I just
kindly ask you to oppose this bill uh
and I sincerely thank you for your time
just for clarification I assume you're
opposed to it but you didn't check it
off on yeah sorry i f it out wrong yeah
I'm opposed to thank you thank
you all
right Eileen is it sagian Sahan again
Sarah Chapman will be next good
morning thank you for listening my name
is een sahagian and I live in Durham New
Hampshire I am here to voice my
opposition to HB
148 I was a teacher for 46 years and I
apologize if I morph into my teacher
voice but it's
coming I had the honor and privilege of
working with many beautiful trans
students
perhaps you do not know what life is
really like for most trans people it
usually takes many years to realize that
you are in the body of the wrong gender
there are years and years of counseling
and the awful awful proven truth about
being trans is this I will say it loudly
and
slowly people in this situation are
often suicide Idol for
years imagine being the loved one of
someone who has suffered and suffered
for years imagine being that person who
has suffered when a transperson who is
finally realigning their body to match
who they are eventually feels
comfortable to go in public and is
finally happy there is absolutely no
reason to afflict upon them the anxiety
of not even being able to use the
bathroom without fear
using the bathroom is a basic bodily
function imagine if someone said to you
representative you may not use this
bathroom there is absolutely no evidence
that trans women are a threatened
bathrooms with this proposed legislation
we are putting fragile frightened and
vulnerable People In Harm's Way and we
are encouraging scary vigilante bathroom
inspectors this legislation is cruel and
I do not think any one of you ran for
office to serve the people of the Live
Free or Die state in order to be cruel
you are good people that is your time
any
questions I did hear the teacher Voice
come out I just want to let you
know Sarah
Chapman followed by is it Veen
Warner he'll be next
good morning members of the committee my
name is Sarah Chapman I'm a resident of
Nottingham and I've lived in New
Hampshire for 42 of my 44 years alive uh
my pronouns are they them I'm non-binary
person and member of this gender diverse
community in New Hampshire and I also
have uh one cisgendered child and one
transgendered child um whose transition
not only saved his young life uh but in
many ways helped me recognize and
understand my own
identity uh my son is by far one of the
most considerate and caring thoughtful
kind funny and wildly creative humans
I've ever known and he's incredibly
courageous to be coming into the world
just fully willing to uh be himself in
this
world I'm beyond grateful for the
support he's re received on his journey
and some of the folks I my deepest
thanks to are here in the building
today uh as you may have guessed I'm
here to speak in opposition to this bill
I ask you to carefully consider the harm
such a decision would cause to the
transgender community and Beyond and to
the broader values of equality and
justice in our
state in my personal experience
recognizing the difference between
gender which I Now understand as a
construct and sex assigned at Birth and
and how so many of us are completely
crushed by the conflation of the two has
been heartbreaking and simultaneously
hopeful as there have become more and
more ways of expressing identity that
allow the two things to be more aligned
when previously they were not looking
back at my own journey I see things so
much more clearly now that I understand
Who I Am from the inside and way that
and the way that conflicts with what
I've been taught and how I've been
treated based on physical
characteristics of the body I was born
into the trajectory of my internal
Journey could have been so much more
peaceful had I the language to
understand this at an earlier age and
the support Express express myself
freely I apologize but that's your time
Ah that's too bad okay well I have a
written if you could yeah that'll be
great to turn that in thank you uh
please
oppose Veen Warner am I getting that
right
Val Valen followed by Stacy EP
Esposito good morning um I'm Valen
Warner uh thank you all for hearing out
so many perspectives today um I am here
speaking in opposite I to House Bill
148 um so I am a Vermont resident uh I
work full-time in New Hampshire I get
all of my medical care in New Hampshire
uh my dearest friends live in New
Hampshire uh currently I do all of my
shopping in New Hampshire although uh
we'll see how things go in the next few
years um I also have been an advocate
for gender inclusive restroom access for
over six years uh what that means is
I've become very familiar with building
codes um if any of you have read uh New
Hampshire State Building Code um which
you really should it's fascinating um
any
multi-user uh public restroom facility
with very limited exceptions is
currently required to be marked by a
sign that says men or women uh I have
complicated feelings about this policy
but the fact is that has been the policy
and the Assumption has always been up
until 2018 that the way the separation
of genders and restrooms would be
enforced
would be by random people using the
restroom to assess whether other people
in the restroom match the sign on the
door or not that was the
Assumption finally in
2018 trans people in New Hampshire got
some protection against being harassed
out of the restroom the only thing this
bill would accomplish is to bring that
back um and I want to be clear uh I
speak on the Wern portion of this bill
because that is something that I am very
familiar with I oppose all aspects of
this bill uh the other portions
targeting uh trans people in uh prisons
and trans people in psychiatric
facilities are blatantly
cruel uh this this bill is a bill about
harassing trans people thank is your
time any questions at all no thank
you Stacy posito followed by Jonah
Sutton
horse hello first time um Dear honorable
members of the Judiciary Committee my
name is Stacy Esposito I'm a resident of
Brooklyn and I'm here in opposition of
HB 148 as a mental health professional
and practice owner with Advanced degrees
in both research and Clinical Psychology
I speak to you from both scientif ific
and clinical perspectives HP 148 is
based on the false premise that
transgender people do not exist a claim
that is not only inhumane but factually
incorrect the existence of trans
identity is widely recognized as a
fundamental part of human diversity by
the vast majority of academics and
professionals the few who deny this are
dismissed within the scientific
communities for pushing baseless
ideology attempting to legislate people
out of existence does not erase them it
denies reality and hurts people I've
worked closely with transgender adults
children and families and I'm deeply
concerned about the harm this bill will
cause in supporting trans clients I've
learned so much about our shared
Humanity I've seen heartbreak and
humility grief and courage pain and
perseverance self-doubt and
self-awareness and a fight for oneself
cuz there is no other way shockingly
enough I haven't heard any processing
related to trying to creep into bathroom
stalls but I have heard heartbreak from
a client that was unable to join a
sports team and had to surrender the
sport altogether due to policy a loss
they had to take to fight for themselves
but a loss nonetheless regardless of
what you all think and how this bill
pans out people are still going to come
to me exploring their gender identity
trans identity isn't going away but if
this bill passes people are going to get
hurt bills like this endorse violence
through forced outing placing an already
vulnerable population at significantly
higher risk bullying is already a
significant problem my clients face at
school and I'm legitimately worried
about their safety being enclosed in
spaces simply trying to use the bathroom
if we're concerned about fairness in
sports or safety and shared spaces let's
engage in nuanced evidence-based
discussions not broad policies that
erase the existence of an entire
population history has shown us what
happens when we legislate against
marginalized communi I apologize but
that's your time okay thank you thank
you Jonah Sutton moris is that correct y
okay followed
by
AJ CIT corid hello ready oh that's okay
thank
you thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh my name is Jonah Sutton
Morse I live in Canterbury New Hampshire
I'm here to testify against this
bill I want to start by affirming that
trans men are men trans women are women
trans non-binary people exist I'm here
today as a parent uh my kids are no
longer at the point where we're doing
potty training and getting out of potty
training but recently enough that I
remember that one of the really
important questions planning a trip is
what do I do if my kid says Daddy I have
to go potty right
now access to public restrooms is access
to public spaces and what this bill says
is anybody who has control over the
signage on public restrooms can tell
trans people you are icky and not wanted
here I understand why a lot of the
discussions about athletic competitions
has been about high school sports
as a former High School swimmer I have
some thoughts about that but also last
year I didn't do any High School sports
I went to a charity 5k with my kids and
some colleagues I went to Canter's toown
Fair it's always the last Saturday in
July and my kids did the obstacle course
those are athletic or sporting events
covered by the bill they're not about
the outcome they're about participating
in community what this bill would say is
anybody who's organizing a 5k or a
Turkey Trot or an obstacle course
can tell trans people you are icky and
not wanted here we know what to call the
behavior of telling people you're icky
and unwanted because of who you are we
call it bigotry and we say it's wrong we
know what to do when we encode that in
legislation we call it state sponsored
discrimination and we say it's
wrong please vote itl in this Bill thank
you thank you
AJ kuty followed by Kathy
Stratton hey um I'm AJ I'm 19 I lived in
New Hampshire my whole life um a lot of
what I wrote down to say I feel like has
kind of already been said the first part
kind of just goes over how Ambiguously
worded the bill is and how that could be
hold on I'll just read it real quick
yeah the purpose of this bill comes
across blatantly contradictory to the
first purpose of New Hampshire's law
discrimination it is a means to
introduce unnecessary government control
in the lives of citizens worded and
bureaucratic equivocation desperately
framed to appear as altruism in the name
of Public Safety um and yeah honestly I
think it's dumb if I read the rest of it
it's all been said I I kind of just want
to tell you guys how I feel after
sitting here the entire time um and
everybody's sphere um I'll reiterate
what someone said earlier which was
thank you for for taking it all in cuz I
mean like it's been a lot for me just
sitting back there and this is your
guys's job um I will add though maybe
I'll need to get like a phone bin or
something like that like how High School
classrooms have but um other than that
thank you so much um but witnessing
everybody's fear even as somebody part
of the queer
Community has shocked me like I know how
scared we all are I think people some
people are more scared than me I think
I'm more privileged than some of those
people who are more scared than me
because I I passed as they would say to
walk into the men's bathroom and not be
questioned I I don't really anticipate
that if this bill was passed it would
really affect my daily life I think that
the queer Community would push through
like we always do but it creates a
terrible world to live in like don't you
guys all just want to live in a nice
place where people love and accept each
other like I mean hearing the fear of
the people who are are with this bill
shook me because that is not an act like
they're not rehearsing that crap like
they're really terrified of gender
men like harming them um and you know
they may say that it is trans people but
you know whatever even if we disagree on
on what they're afraid of like I feel
their time okay yeah I I would just say
consider everybody's fear and if and if
you don't want New Hampshire to be a
scary place oppose this bill
please Kathy Sutton followed by
Stephanie colie
good morning Mr chair excuse me Kathy
Stratton had to excuse herself uh she
was here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Medical Society um I am here in herstead
my name is Mara Weston and again I am
here today on behalf of the New
Hampshire Medical Society I have a pink
card for the record and we'll submit
that along with my written testimony the
New Hampshire Medical Society is a
nonprofit nonpartisan Society of
Physicians and other healthc care
clinicians our mission is to advocate
for the well-being of our patients for
our profession and the betterment of
Public Health in New Hampshire we are
here today in opposition to HB 148 we
envision a state in which personal and
public health are high priorities and
all people who live and work here
have access to Quality
Healthcare this bill discriminates
against transgender
individuals denying transgender
individuals Access to Health Care
endangers their health safety and
well-being leading to negative Health
outcomes and heightened stigma and
discrimination the report of the 2015 US
transgender survey from the national
Center for transgender equity which
surveyed
27,000 transgender gender people found
that 40% reported a suicide attempt that
rate is nine times higher than in the
general US
population the New Hampshire medical
society believes that this Bill runs a
fowl of our mission and the well-being
of our patients it is harmful and
discriminatory we urge you to vote and
expedient to legislate I appreciate your
time thank you thank you any questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much Stephanie
colie followed by
Deborah
house hello everyone thank you excuse me
for taking my testimony my name is
Stephanie colie I live in Santa Conway
New Hampshire
and I am here to oppose HB
148 um the reason I I've been involved
in the trans Rights Movement for quite a
while um we were here back in 2017 and
18 when finally we passed the
anti-discrimination law um and I sat
through countless hours of hearings and
meetings testifying Etc and um during
that time we heard a lot of stories um
hypothetical stories how if this pass
they would open up um basically women's
restrooms to predators and everything
else we have real life not hypothetical
but real life experience now to know
after seven years since 2018 that that
simply isn't true um so all the
hypothetical fearmongering is really
without Merit um so that would be the
first point I would take the second
point I would say is that um I don't
know I I would ask any of the women on
this committee would you feel
comfortable going into a men's room I
certainly don't and if I if you don't
why would I um many of us have to use a
women's restroom um and do it our
medical transition I simply can't use a
urino trust me it won't work so um again
I would respect have you be respectful
of us human beings um another point is
again people have said this how will
this be enforced
birth certificates to get in and who
else is going to be police it will be
women who are tall short hear deep
voices anybody who doesn't fit a
particular stereotype will be forced to
prove themselves and that is not a
society I think we want to live in
another point is think about if we do
this trans men now going to have to use
the ladies room I apologize com that be
okay thank you and again I UR you to
vote itl on this thank you thank you
Deborah
house followed by Grace
Murray good afternoon chairman Manion
Deborah house uh I am the President of
the American Federation of teach
teachers New Hampshire and I represent
um
3500 teachers and education
professionals across the grent state as
well as uh Town employees we are here in
opposition of H billb 148 um I just want
to focus on a few points we oppose the
whole bill but there's a few things that
uh I want to make sure we say our public
schools accept all students and uh we
want we need to we have a responsibility
to make sure they all feel included and
that they all feel they belong in our
schools all students should be able to
fully participate in their public school
that includes being able to participate
in sports and being able to use the
bathroom so we do not want to be forced
to discriminate against any students
which we feel we would have to if this
bill passed my next point is if this
bill passes how will it be enforced many
of our schools have 300 500 even a
thousand students in them not every
teacher knows every student so imagine
this scenario as a staff person you're
in the hallway during passing time you
see a student going into the bathroom
the student is dressed uh you know in a
skirt and a and a blouse and looks like
a girl okay do you have to question that
that activity what if the student's uh
appearance is more ambiguous like mine
was in high school I was tall broad
shouldered but developed late I wore
jeans and a baggy shirt most days would
you have to stop that student and
question them how do we um enforce this
do students have to carry their original
birth certificate with them to prove whe
whether their biological sex at Birth as
register on their birth certificate
before they can go in the bathroom going
to be an awfully long line and there's
only a few minutes between classes we
have to check each one or are you
suggesting a different way of checking
do we have to question them and more
carefully examine how they're dressed
how they walk how they talk are we now
doing gender profiling of students
between classes before they can use the
bathroom is anyone suggesting we do
General Bill checks so we oppose this we
don't want to be forced to harass our
students thank you any
questions representa
cutell thank you Mr chair and um thank
you for taking my question it's nice to
see you on a different committee yes
good to see you again we haven't spoken
in a while yes we haven't um my question
is so if a girl on an athletic team
feels um like she's being discriminated
against because there's boys a boy a
transgender girl
playing on her athletic team would you
defend her in that situation if she felt
discriminated
against well your question is lar
confusing because you couldn't even
quite tell me who was uh on the team
with her so um I'm going to let someone
else answer that question thank you
because you've had a lot of testimony
about that already yep any other
questions representative Horgan um yes
in your experience um the schools when a
child enrolls to the school do they even
does the school even know the child's
entire medical history so isn't it
possible that some uh
trans trans girls or trans boys could
enroll at the school without the
school's
knowledge the medical history we have is
what the parent provides to us and it is
usually very
limited um it is usually related to you
know like allergies things we would need
to know about things that might cause an
emergency situation in the school um
often a vaccine record so that we are
aware of what communicable diseases they
they might um you know be Pro might be
vaccinated against protected against um
and if there is a need for the school
nurse to know about a
particular um issue that might come up
at school so if you've got a medically
fragile child we would have more
extensive medical records but that child
would most likely have an IEP or a 504
plan so uh beyond that we don't keep a
lot of medical records at school because
that's a privacy thing and you know
asking for students to carry their
original birth certificate around with
them that sounds like a privacy thing to
me
too yeah any other
questions I heard it oh sorry that's
okay okay thank you
Y Grace muray
followed by Caitlyn
kellerer good afternoon uh Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Grace Murray and I'm
from Amhurst New Hampshire I work as the
political director for New Hampshire
youth movement and I oppose HB
148 while I have multiple issues with
this bill I'm sure those have already
been covered or will be covered by other
testimonies today and I'm hoping to
offer more of a different perspective um
than has already been
spoken this bill focuses on three
situational classifications but I'll be
just uh just addressing bathrooms um the
text this Bell says that it aims to
protect the Privacy rights and safety of
citizens but a bill that opens the door
to discrimination invasive questions and
possibly dangerous assumptions does No
Such Thing passing this bill would allow
an environment where instead of people
just being able to use the restroom for
its intended uses they would then have
to worry about being accused of whether
or not they
belong I have polycystic ovarian
syndrome PCOS for short a complex
hormonal condition that affects around
one in 10 women in the
US one of the many symptoms of PCOS is
facial hair women will wax bleach pluck
shave and do all other kinds of hair
removal because frankly it can be
embarrassing to have hair where you
don't want it some women don't choose to
remove it though and maybe there are
maybe you're like in between Wax
appointments what I'm trying to get at
is that it's not uncommon to see by
these standards a biological woman with
facial hair what should these women do
when they need to use the restroom
should they be sub subjected to the
scrutiny of others when they want to use
a woman's restroom I shouldn't have to
explain my medical history to to a
stranger so I can use the restroom what
if they're not believed should that
woman then use the men's restroom or
just hope she finds a gender neutral
bathroom how does that protect our
privacy or our safety I'll tell you
right now it really
doesn't if this bill passes that's
exactly the kind of situation you'll be
putting every woman with PCOS in I urge
you to oppose HB 148 thank
you perfect timing again any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Caitlyn
kellerer followed by attorney Ian huitt
hello um I'm cat kellerer my pronouns
are they them and I'm going to be
speaking a little quickly I'm testifying
against HB 148 today because we've heard
some testimony of support today based
not out of personal experience but fear
so I'd like to speak on the violence
this bill and its writer alleges to
protect against by sharing a few of my
personal experiences I'm concerned this
bill creates a precedent for policing
bathrooms that results in justification
of violence in the public culture the
first time I experienced physical
violence because of the bathroom I was
at a Walmart in North Carolina on
hurricane disaster relief I was with two
young 18-year-old gender non-conforming
people who were on my Disaster Response
Team I was responsible for them a grown
man stopped Us coming out of the
bathroom harassed us through screaming
in the building staled us out of the
building and we were chased in the
parking lot I was swung at by a grown
man and hit and went to the ER because I
was putting myself between the two young
people I was responsible for ironically
we were using a bathroom based on
assigned gender markers to try and avoid
this aggression that certain kinds of
states and regions are known for the
kind of state ours could become this
aggression can be a regular part of our
Lives as gender nonconforming people I
was first sexually harassed at Broken
Ground School in conquered in fourth
grade when a male classmate slapped my
butt and then grabbed my breast at 10
years old I was assaulted in the
Christen mccul auditorium at conquered
High School when a male Class C sorry
classmate put his hand into my pants
during a puppeted presentation relying
on my embarrassment to not speak up I
was date raped by an alleged friend male
in a spiked beverage on a night I wasn't
drinking violence is not coming from
trans people and making them feel unsafe
is not going to stop the sexual and
physical assault perpetrated against
women and children because trans people
are not the perpetrators they are also
the Survivors by passing this bill there
are people who will assume you are
giving your permission for
discrimination it is upholding patterns
of violence perpetrated by bigots
against the trans Community if you
support this bill you aren't protecting
me you aren't protecting women or
children you aren't protecting the trans
Community you're inviting a societal
standard of violence against us all
please vote
itl and I'm happy to take any questions
any questions my backgrounds in Lakes so
seeing n thank you thank you attorney
Ian hwit followed by Cara
cabraal Mr chairman and members of the
committee Ian hu appearing for
Cornerstone I will not try to cram any
dense legal analysis into two minutes
but I will say I'd be happy to answer
any legal questions and explain why this
bill does not contradict title 7 or
354a or discuss legal definitions of
biological sex in the meantime I will
just say I think most of the testimony
I've heard in opposition to this bill
seems like testimony against a bill that
would make being transgender illegal
actually of course this bill just says
the biological sex exists and that the
state may different iate based on
biological sex sometimes that has been a
feature of every historic legal system
from Egypt to Japan since there have
been legal systems it happens every day
in New Hampshire when for example
someone is arrested and I've heard
virtually no one who speaking in
opposition to this bill explain why they
think biological sex does not exist or
explain why the state should be
prohibited from ever differentiating
based on biological sex thank you
question questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your testimony
sir would you agree with the prime
sponsor that if you want to just get
along you should pass this
bill I think that this bill is a
well-crafted compromise by
representative kofalt and uh chief
justice Lynn who contributed
substantially to it in the last session
and I think what you're getting at is
that this bill allows locality by
locality School District by School
District agency by agency decision
making and so it would lead to people in
different communities around the state
enacting different policies as they best
suit their
communities any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you cara
cabw followed by McKenzie
West thank you so much for the
opportunity need to speak my name is
Cara cabal and I've been a resident of
New Hampshire for 36 years I live in
Madbury I strongly urge you to oppose HB
148 this bill will cause significant
harm to transgender and gender
non-conforming people broadly and to
youth specifically it fails to address
any real problems and instead creates
new avenues for harm I've had the
privilege of working with lgbtq plus
youth for over a decade they're a
delight they deserve better I've seen
firsthand the challenges these young
people face and the toll it takes when
they aren't able to be who they truly
are it erodes their confidence and their
mental health and these challenges will
only grow worse with policies like HB
148 and I feel the weight of their fear
in this current moment by advancing HB
148 you are exacerbating the trauma they
already experience from bullying
discrimination and rejection depriving
them of the opportunity to live
authentically and reach their full
potential how can you advocate for
children's safety while supporting a
policy that risks exacerbating their
suffering there's no credible evidence
to suggest that classifying People based
on biological sex and restrooms locker
rooms or Sports improve safety or
fairness it creates this bill creates a
false Narrative of danger the ambiguity
surrounding how the bill will be
enforced will only lead to confus uson
discrimination and increased violence I
implore you to oppose HB 148 the harm it
will cause cannot be understated thank
you so
much thank you McKenzie West and this is
the last card that I have so anyone here
that wants to speak on this bill that
hasn't turned a pink card
in good afternoon members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is McKenzie
West I am currently ly a resident of
Pembrook and I'm here to oppose this
bill unlike a lot of people who have
spoken here today I I was not born here
and I did not grow up in this state I
grew up and started my transition in
Vermont and only moved here last year
now you have heard a lot on how this
bill is harmful but i' would like to
speak as to why I moved to this state I
moved here for greater opportunities and
to build a life in the granite state in
making this decision as an out
transgender woman a big part of the
reason that I ultimately decided to move
here after rigorous research and
Analysis was the protections that the
state has offered for people like me I
moved here because I knew I would be
safe in employment housing public life
and that I would have a bright future
however with chilling effects of this
bill and the many like this I question
my I question my future in this state
how safe I will be and whether or not
this is really the best place for not
only myself but for other trans people
like me with friends in other states how
do I ultimately choose to stay when my
ultimate when my future in this state is
looking increasingly uncertain how do I
tell my friends and queer other queer
folks in less safe states that New
Hampshire is a sa safe state to move to
how am I to really lay down roots in
this state when it is increasingly when
it increasingly seems as though people
like me are no longer welcome I urge you
to vote itl on HB
148 thank
you thank
you again that's the last card I have
for this
bill so at this point I'm going to close
the hearing on House Bill 148 and we'll
be in recess until 1 o'clock thank
you
e
e e
okay it's a little bit after 1 o'clock
I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill 641 and recognize
representative Linda harth G gas right
to introduce the bill
there you go good afternoon Mr chair and
and committee members I am
representative Linda Harriet gathright
out of Hillsboro 10 Nashville Awards
nine and I'm here to introduce my bill
establishing a private right of action
for civil rights violations HB
641 and in short I'm going to keep it
short because I have others that's
coming behind me to
speak um in short it's asking that we
allow a person to have the right to have
a lawyer to represent them for any civil
rights violations they think might have
been against them so with that
said I would recommend that you leave
your questions to those that come behind
me there's quite a few
speakers unless you have something
specific to me yes representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair thank
you representative for taking my
question um I'm under the impression
that somebody already has the right for
a private right of action and violation
of a discrimination under this chapter
under the Human Rights Commission you
absolutely do but right now today you
have to go through the AG's office so
this will supplement that just to follow
up maybe the AG could probably help this
I believe the private right of I believe
an individual can file a case in the
human rights division not not with the
AG along with the AG but I believe an
individual themselves are able to do
that I'm going to say it's not quite
like that because I know others
individuals that took the case outside
of New
Hampshire any other
questions seeing none thank
you representative Jonah
wheer thank you Mr chairman ranking
member Smith friends on the house
Judiciary Committee I'm sure that
representative goth handled it well so
I'm just here to affirm my support
there's a significant rise in these
civil rights cases a 465 per rise in
these civil rights cases according to
the Attorney General's office and
allowing a private right of action for
these individuals to address those civil
rights cases I think is a very simple
common nonpartisan way to move forward
in this state so I'll let the good
lawyers and people who have come here
today with expert testimony
testify more comprehensively to what is
actually in the bill what's being passed
around right now is an amendment to HB
641 which would amend section three
section one by inserting and replacing
the following as found in the bill for
the third paragraph of section one um
would that Mr chair that's my testimony
I hope I can be of service in any way in
passing this legislation onto the
governor's
desk any
questions seeing none thank you and
representative Harry keth can I get a
pink card at some point from you if you
wouldn't if you wouldn't mind yeah thank
you Sean Lock
good morning chair Manion uh members of
the House Judiciary Committee my name is
or I am Senior Assistant Attorney
General Shan lock I am here to testify
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Department of Justice the department
doesn't take a position on the
underlying Bill representative Smith's
favorite comment I get to make um but we
do support the amendment we actually
asked for this particular Amendment so
if you were to vote ought to pass we'd
ask that you ought to pass as amended um
to the necessary though I do want to
provide informational testimony about
the Civil Rights Act the Civil Rights
unit the work that we do at the Attorney
General's office because the statute
amends the Civil Rights Act I thought
I'd begin with a little background on
that particular act and I'll touch on um
representative Alexander's question as
well U but the Civil Rights Act was
passed in 1999 and it prohibits
interfering with rights and lawful
activities of another through actual or
threatened uses of force violence
property damage or trespass when those
unlaw acts are motivated by protected
characteristics including race religion
national origin disability gender
identity sexual orientation and several
others it authorizes the Attorney
General to bring actions to protect
those rights we can seek the Attorney
General's office can seek civil
penalties of up to $5,000 per violation
a restraining order an injunction to
protect victims their communities and
further the goals of the Civil Rights
Act which is the free exercise of
people's lawful activities
we can also if an order is put in place
and later violated by the person who has
the order against them pursue criminal
charges if and when those orders are
violated the goal of the Civil Rights
Act is to facilitate public protection
by creating an Avenue to use civil
process to Shield victims their Comm and
their communities from future harm in
scenarios where civil they may not have
access to those protections you know all
of these uses of force uses of violence
property damage there may be Tor claims
that can be brought to seek remedies to
seek damages for those but you can't
where there are damages that could make
a person whole you wouldn't necessarily
get the restraining order the injunctive
relief that the Civil Rights Act
envisions and that's its primary
function is to create a mechanism to
protect rights going forward and to
prevent future harm not just to redress
what has happened in the past now in
more recent history in December of 2017
just about 7 years ago then Attorney
General McDonald created the Civil
Rights unit to exercise The Authority
that had been vested in the Attorney
General's office and in 2019 I came to
lead that
unit and shortly after doing so we
issued protocols to all law enforcement
agencies in the state setting out what
we expect from them in terms of
identifying not just Civil Rights Act
violations but also potential hate
crimes if and when they occur in those
communities as a result of that since
shortly thereafter 2020 2021 because of
the pandemic um every officer that goes
through the police academy receives a
two-hour Block in training of training
in identifying hate crimes identifying
potential identity bias or hate
motivated Behavior to facilitate better
better kind of hate crime charges but
also better more Civil Rights Act
enforcement
actions since then we've seen an
increase in complaints and referrals and
contacts with the public so and as of 24
2024 last year we received about 215
complaints whether they're from the
public or referrals from law enforcement
about a quarter to a third of those
complaints constitute what we would call
potential Civil Rights Act violations so
it's alleging or maybe alleging things
that are violations of the
statute many of those cases some of many
of those cases if they involve things
like vandalism it may be difficult to
identify suspects so not every single
complaint or referral we receive leads
to an action because we need a defendant
we need someone to charge with the
violation um some of these cases involve
juveniles and so those cases may be
confidential and we can't discuss those
cases publicly but we you know we review
them we screen them we work with law
enforcement to further the investigation
to the extent we can to identify who if
and when to bring those cases
forward with that increase in referrals
and complaints we received we've been
bringing more enforcement actions over
the years and we work closely with law
enforcement to identify and and and
establish when if and when violations
occur now looking at at this piece of
legislation House Bill 641 although
we're not taking a position on the
underlying bill on creating that private
right of action we're glad to see that
the department we were glad to see in
the original version of the bill that we
would receive notice when these
complaints are filed by private citizens
so we know when these cases are
happening we know what those outcomes
are because we would then be tasked with
if there are violations of any orders
bringing the criminal
charges but we proposed the amendment to
also allow the department to intervene
in those cases so it's not if we see
something that warrants greater
protection for the public than maybe
what would be resolved between the
private parties we can intervene and ask
for that relief we can make sure that
the public at large is protected and not
just the plaintiff in the case the same
thing is true and that's kind of where
the concern and why we put forward that
Amendment and ask the prime sponsor to
bring that Amendment
forward the last thing I want to touch
on before I hit on some some questions
here that had come up just considering
the cost because there are fiscal there
should be a f note with this um we do
view it as at the very at best cost
neutral if you know or more likely it
would increase some of the demands and
resources placed on the department
because we're going to be receiving
additional complaints and cases that
have been filed from sources outside of
what we have been in the past so if
someone decides not to go to law
enforcement but to file an action we'll
get notice of that that we wouldn't have
before and we'll have to screen that and
determine whether or not it warrants
intervention so that you know we we do
see that there may be increased work um
that we're kind of happy to take on um a
few notes Here I I I want to I did it
yesterday in the Senate with the similar
version of this bill the 465 per
increase that is total number of
complaints and points of contact we have
and the Civil Rights Union it's not
necessarily Civil Rights Act violations
that have been alleged um I try to
clarify that every time I give numbers
to the media and they don't put that
disclaimer on it they just report the
the numbers um but we certainly are
seeing an increase in hate motivated
behavior and Civil Rights Act violations
I just don't have hard numbers for that
um I also want to clarify we're not
overwhelmed with the work that we have
we we are able to keep up with the Civil
Rights Act violations that we receive
we're able to file those as they come in
um and to the question about 354a versus
354b so three the private rights of
action you're talking about with the
commission for human rights those fall
out of RSA chapter 354a that's the
state's law against discrimination which
prohibits discrimination housing
employment public accommodations and
public education yes private individuals
have the right to file chart claims with
the Human Rights Commission alleging
that 354b which this amends is the Civil
Rights Act and only the attorney general
has the authority to bring actions under
the Civil Rights Act there's no private
right there might be again there's you
know maybe underlying tort claims or
things like that that someone could
bring and 354b addresses that it allows
for individuals who may be we bring a
case they can still bring their own
civil action to collect whatever damages
they might be entitled to so there's
still some Avenue but it doesn't have
the kind of the the injunctive power
that comes with 354b if you're bringing
a private torque claim um the only other
thing I'll note and I I flagged this and
I think there'll be a couple other folks
talking about it but I mentioned it to
the sponsor it's just there's some
language in paragraph 2 around not
necessarily about the damages itself but
I think it's lines 10 through 12 it
talks about methods of competition and
Acts or practice that seem to be drawn
from the consumer protection act it just
might want to be cleaned up and
clarified to make it fit this statute
rather than think oh well it sounds like
OS just kind of pulled language out of
the consumer protection act and kind of
plugged it in here so we just might want
to clean up that language a little bit
to make it fit the Civil Rights Act
rather than language referring to
um unfair competition and deceptive
practices and with that I'm happy to
take any questions you all have
representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question can you um
provide and I you might have said it the
amount of complaints that were received
last year through your division of civil
rights violations yep so um for the
total number of complaints we received
there were 215 those alleging potential
Civil Rights Act violations and I'll say
last year was the first time we started
segregating the numbers um was it was
about I want to say it was about 50 to
55 that we received of that 215 50 to 55
were potential Civil Rights Act
violations okay and if I could follow up
follow up um is there any um were there
any complaints or potential violations
that the Attorney General's office did
not feel like they had adequate
resources to follow up with no CU we
work a lot with local law enforcement
around investigating those complaints
and actions so we do pursue that we do
have additional resources now we have an
investigator that's they split between
our unit and the election law unit so we
have some support if we need further
investigation that local law enforcement
can't do um so we have the resources to
follow up in that regard usually if
we're not taking an action it's either
because a suspect hasn't been identified
so we just don't have a person to charge
or after we assess the complaint and the
evidence we determine and we'll let the
person know this that there is an action
that we can pursue okay thank you any
other questions representative
Smith thank you very much for being here
um just first a little CL clarification
you suggested that we should clean up
the language does the Attorney General's
office have a specific suggestion that
they could pass on to us of how they
think that that ambiguity would be I can
take a look at it and do so I'll you
know I haven't yet thought about it
because the damages piece is a little
beyond our purview we wouldn't be
getting damages but I can take a look at
that and see if there's anything oh that
I hope that doesn't count as a question
no that was a a recommendation maybe
yeah I think so request thank you very
much request maybe I I do have a
question
um uh
I going back to the beginning you talked
about you said that um the the law
enforcement people have two hours of
training on hate
crimes um as you uh so clearly
stated the incidence of those crimes is
increasing
significantly do you believe that two
hours of training is adequate to capture
the
importance of that training for the work
that law enforcement is expected to do
only because I do this I could probably
spend entire days talking to law
enforcement about different aspects of
it but the point of the training block
for a new officer is just to give kind
of it it I I often describe some of the
sections when we talk about identifying
hate crimes as these are Flags like this
is when something should be kind of
going you should be hearing an alarm in
the distance kind of in your mind that
there's more to look at here and maybe
contacting our office so we can assist
them as they kind of conduct that
investigation so it's not meant to be an
all-encompassing they will now know
everything to know it's about knowing
when to ask for additional help or when
to look more deeply at a case than to
kind of Simply kind of brush off
something as potential coincidence or
happen stance to know that there could
be more there I mean there's you know
some of what we talk about talk about
hate symbols and what to kind what
common ones are you could do entire days
of training on different hate symbols
that exist so you know I think the point
is to ground them in um kind of what to
look for and where there should be kind
of like I said red flags for further
followup well also as part of that
training um we have we go through a
series of case studies where we take
fact patterns and they take and they
apply some of the things they've learned
about in the training to actual fact
pattern or to fact patterns so kind of
crafted from cases we may have brought
or cases that maybe kind of people might
recognize but the idea is to Think
Through what would happen What would I
ask for what evidence would I gather how
do I further my suspicion of potential
bias motivation and and so they can kind
of think in that moment because that's
what they're going to be doing um out on
patrol thank you is that is that
training done yearly or is it a one-time
training it's um so for the police
academy it's every police cadet so it's
I think I actually do it six times a
year but it's each class of police
officers and then we have follow-up
training we've done some training for
existing officers as well as prosecutors
around identifying and Prosecuting hate
crime offenses and what that might do in
the criminal case if you were to charge
something as a hate crime what you need
to do as a result of that thank you
representative tur yeah thanks um real
real brief and thanks for taking the
question real real briefly it may not be
your area um if we're talking about
amending the language a little bit I
noticed in the analysis it mentions
punitive damages uh by name and my
understanding and if you could could
verify or not that our state doesn't
award punitive damages I'm not sure how
important it is that that gets that that
gets fixed but I think that language I
it's not the way I read the bill itself
but that that terminology seemed
inconsistent for what I understood I I
I'd share that I I would agree the state
as a matter of the New Hampshire Court
doesn't recognize punitive damages a lot
of times in statutes where there might
be what we would probably call punitive
damages it's enhanced compensatory
damages um but I don't see the reference
to it in the bill I just see it in that
analysis piece so I'm not sure that
that's what would that you would be able
to say these are punitive damages it
certainly sets a minimum damage
threshold um but I think um I it
certainly doesn't reference punitive
damages here like I've seen in other
statutes or other bills yeah thanks I I
don't know what the the relevance of the
analysis after this moves on is I just
was Raising it as potential correction I
know when we when it goes into the rsas
all that anal is gone so um it's just
the it's just the changes listed out in
the
bill representative
ban thank you answering my question I
just wanted to know does this
deal he hasn't answered it yet so hold
on and ask he's giving you a hard time
go ahead oh go
ahead does this address students at all
or is it 18 above or what is it so
anyone can be charged when this was a
big point of debate actually in 1999
when the Civil Rights Act was passed
about whether juveniles could be covered
under it juveniles can be and we've
brought actions I think internally we'd
be uncomfortable bringing actions
against someone under the age of 16
probably but um we have brought actions
against 16 and 17 year
olds um and and it involved incidents
that occurred in school um but in other
circumstances particularly again with
younger juveniles we leave that to the
juvenile justice system and um you like
families schools to address the behavior
at least in the Civil Rights Act there
may be issues of discrimination law and
public education that we'd get involved
in but that's a different Target when
we're looking at those
cases any other questions representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question what type of cases are you
seeing it runs a range so we have cases
from acts of violence we just Pro we
just actually received an order a few
weeks ago in a case where um it was
during a relationship had a romantic
relationship had ended um the defendant
in that case had kind of cornered the
victim and convinced her to travel with
him she to try to escape disclosed that
she believed she was bisexual and he
began to savagely beat her he broke her
eye orbital um he strangled her he bit
her on the arm and he hit her with a bat
so we brought so we have cases from that
to you know and those would be what I
call kind of I mean that's probably one
of the most egregious fact patterns
we've had but we've had individuals one
of the first cases I brought was an
individual who brandished a gas hose at
a black family at a gas station in
Seabrook and threatened to douse them
with gasoline and set them on fire um
while shouting racial slurs at them so
you know there are some very outrageous
fact patterns that have come across my
desk over the past several years many of
our complaints though that we receive I
would say our vandalism it's a very
common thing and a lot of times these
locations are chosen because of their
remote nature so the lonia state school
has been a target of vandalism multiple
times with
swastikas um tags kind of supporting
neonnazi and white supremacist groups
tags calling out individual members of
the Jewish community and threatening
them with violence so um again it's it's
it's a wide array of different things um
but you know in know some of these
circumstances people choose locations
especially for vandalism that are hard
to you know there aren't cameras there
aren't you know contrary to what we all
believe there are not cameras everywhere
in the state of New Hampshire recording
all that we do um and so a lot of people
go undetected just the violence the
suffering is what gets
reported thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you thank
you Michael
Atkins good afternoon Mr chairman
ranking member Smith um my name is
Michael Akin I'm an attorney Shaheen and
Gordon at our Peterborough New Hampshire
office I've been a member of the bar in
New Hampshire since
1989 in a volunteer capacity I'm the
legal redress chair for the greater NASA
NAACP um I'm here to speak in support of
House Bill 641 on behalf of all of the
branches of the NAACP in New Hampshire
of which there is one in the greater
nsha Manchester Sea Coast and we have an
NAACP chapter College chapter at
Dartmouth for those that are not
familiar the NAACP is the oldest civil
rights organization in the United States
formed in
1909 with a simple mission that includes
protecting the civil rights of all
people the purpose of HB 641 as you've
heard is simply to provide a private
cause of action um for people who are
grieved and the victim of offenses
already prohibited by RSA
354b I think it's important to know that
all of our surrounding states that have
similar statutes uh my understanding of
Vermont Maine and Massachusetts provide
a private cause of action for its
citizens not only the Attorney General
can uh bring a suit um attorney lock uh
indicated that the amendment about
having the ability of the Attorney
General to intervene uh um we have no
problem with that we think that's a
great idea we look to continuing to work
with the Attorney General's office and
the great work that they're doing in
this regard because the simple facts are
since 2017 the complaints being an
increase in
465 in the state you asked about fact
patterns this is not isolated it's not
in one Community it's from the madok
region to the Lakes Region to Manchester
to nashwa to the Sea Coast and being a
member of the bar for almost 36 years
now I've never seen conduct like this in
in the communities throughout our state
and if all of the complaints that are
made that attorney lock talked about to
the Attorney General's office think
about the number of complaints that
Susie Jones or Joe Smith whoever is the
victim they're not calling the Attorney
General's office right so this is I
think just a sample that's only the
complaints that the Attorney General's
office um receives so again I ask uh uh
that this committee support this um and
representative Smith she stepped out um
I will work with attorney lock to clean
up some of the language that he
suggested I think he uh hit it uh
correctly and I'm I'm happy to take any
questions anyone may have representative
uh
bur thank you Mr chair and thank you
counselor for taking my
question to put it
simply um this is an ability
irrespective irrespective of the
Attorney General's office though they
can intervene irrespective of the
Attorney General's office for an
individual to bring a private suit uh
for civil rights
violation so assuming that's what
happens my question has to do with an
attempted waiver of the right to damages
uh shall be voided
unenforcable so I'm a plaintiff you're a
defendant I sue you um under this
statute and at some point we reach an
agreement it can be uh before
a court adjudication or perhaps even
after adjudication and we may agree on
an injunction we may agree on a number
of things does this bill
prohibit me as the plaintiff from
waving uh I don't know it's called
statutory damages or whatever
but any agreement that we make that
waves the damage aspect would be void
I'm wondering what the reason for that
is or if I just have it wrong sure the
answer to your question is no it would
not prevent or wave anyone's rights um
in the hypothetically you provided there
was a civil suit and again we're talking
civil actions here and someone um I'm
the defendant you're the plaintiff and
you're hypothetical um you bring an
action and I agree to resolve the case
with you I say yes I did it and I won't
do it anymore and um we agree that there
won't be any damages that's fine that's
not prohibited or we agree there would
be some that's fine not
prohibited following up then what's the
what's the purpose of this line in the
bill yeah a couple things I think that
um RSA 358a the consumer protection act
uh was looked at as a model for this
version and draft uh the bill that's
submitted um and I think that situation
would be in that same hypothetical you
and I had some relationship and you
wanted to enter agreement with me I was
your
tenant okay and you wanted to enter an
agreement with me that say hey here's
the lease and by the way you can't ever
say I violated your civil rights that
would be prohibited you can't enter an
agreement and wave your fundamental
civil rights
thank you you're welcome any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
chairman all
Phillips thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Paul
Phillips I live in Plymouth New
Hampshire I'm an attorney in private
practice I also served as a member of
the New Hampshire commission for human
rights from 2014 to
2018 and as as its chair from 2015 to
2018 I appear here today as a private
citizen to speak in support of HB 641 FN
which would create a private right of
action for any person aggrieved by a
violation of New Hampshire's Civil
Rights Act HB 641 adds a necessary elent
that has been missing from our state
civil rights act the ability of an
individual or business to speak for
themselves and to vindicate their own
rights in
court HB 641 is also a necessary coraly
to the private right of action which has
been available in the federal civil
rights act since
1871 I have the greatest respect and
admiration for the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office which added a
civil rights unit during my tenure as
chair of the Human Rights Commission and
with whom I had a cordial and
collaborative relationship during my
time as chair nonetheless the State
Attorney General's office uh advocates
for the best interest of the State of
New Hampshire and while those interests
May overlap and indeed often do overlap
with individual interests in protecting
their own civil rights the state has
limited human and financial resources
and cannot possibly give attention to
every meritorious
[Music]
case that resource Gap is also true of
the Human Rights
Commission which does the best it can
with limited resources but in answer to
representative
Alexander's questions it's an agency of
limited
jurisdiction it only adjudicates cases
involving discrimination and housing
employment public accommodations and
public
education uh chapter 35 4 a is the is
the human rights commission's enabling
act uh this this uh bill would amend
354b which sweeps much more
broadly the Human Rights Commission
also um is unable to give Equitable
relief uh the damages that it gives are
limited to strictly compensatory
damages
um and uh the resource Gap at the Human
Rights Commission is is clear in that in
the fact that they have a a a statutory
time frame within which they're supposed
to resolve their cases and for many
years now they have far exceeded that
statutory time frame uh it's it's a it's
a great agency but unfortunately it's
not an effective
agency uh for handling these kinds of
cases uh HP 641 addresses these resource
gaps by by empowering individuals and
businesses to advocate for
themselves to bring actions in their own
names to assert their own rights to
speak up for
themselves and to have their day in
court whenever they have suffered an an
injustice that rises to a violation of
the
law private rights of action already
exist throughout New Hampshire law this
legislature over time has authorized
private rights of action in the state's
consumer protection act in the patients
Bill of Rights in the school safety act
in the municipal liability act in the
political advertising law and just last
year you enacted the uh law prohibiting
the use of deep fakes which has a
private right of action this list is not
exhaustive but it gives you a sense of
the scope of the private rights of
action that are already available to
granted Staters in the
law our state courts are by now well
accustomed to handling these types of
cases as part of their
dockets HB 641 FN authorizes individuals
to take responsibility for themselves it
is an act of individual empowerment at a
time when government is shrinking I urge
you to give this power to the people of
New Hampshire and to approve HB 641
FN thank you I'm happy to take any
questions any questions sentive Bur
a brief question that just occurred to
me perhaps might have gone better to
attorney lock is part of your testimony
has been
that the private action contemplated by
this bill uh gives more powers of uh
of making things better than the current
uh statute under which the AG's office
operates terms of injunctive or whatever
other kind we leave would it make sense
uh at some point also to increase the
power of the AG's office in terms of his
potential
remedies uh I I'm not going to speak to
that I I'm attorney in private practice
I have uh an occasional case that goes
up against the state of New Hampshire
I'm not generally an advocate of
increasing the power of the state um but
I would leave that to Mr Lock to answer
that question better than I thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
chairman Harriet
Katie good afternoon been a long time
since I've been here only three
now exist that were here when I was
here so um you just pull that microphone
a little bit closer yeah it's good to
see so many people serving the
public I come with only a couple of
minutes one is this bill doesn't do
something that for years I fought for
special education for my son who was a
high IQ and had a a
damage to the brain through a baseball
bat hitting his head and it caused an
auditory sequential learning
disability which caused him not to hear
all the
instructions my point being that from
first grade through sixth grade I went
before hearing officer at the State
Board of Education who found for me I
went before complaints to the Department
of Education who found down for
me I hired people
myself nothing
worked and what I feel is there are a
couple of things that need to be added
in the student handbook there should be
a section of
501 uh C4 I'm I'm not quite Public Law
anyways
Federal and so you should in amend this
to have a section in the student
handbook I
believe that tells the parents their
right for a handicapped
child I don't is this
the yeah this is Bill
641 that's what I've got I'm saying the
bill needs to have an
addition the second thing is I
believe that if there were fine
for violations
of children's rights under handicapped
education we would have
accountability there are no
fines that you have I had to go
to the New England Department of
Education with my complaint
before the school district was punished
by making them put out a pamphlet for
every child in the school to take home
telling of their
rights and the further things that they
did at the
school but this bill doesn't
do
enough I support it but I think you need
to
have a section to
show at
501c4 and if you had for everybody in
the school the right to a pamphlet
telling them their rights under handicap
education it would very
nicely give the parent the idea of what
they could expect for their
trial thank you any questions
seeing none thank
you Ray
elely hello and thank you for hearing me
and
um I'm Ray elely from
Lichfield and uh I do SE while I
celebrate the fact that we do have an
attorney general and they do seem to be
trying that's a good thing so but I do
know that these things are under
reported I know of one myself just
recently where a lot of stuff happened
but nothing was written down and there's
no record of it at
all so we do need a greater mechanism
even though I'm not accusing anybody but
I think the way the thing is done now
even though we are in good faith trying
to fix things I think that it uh
violates the 14th Amendment a little bit
the uh first section where it says no
State shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the Privileges or
immunities of citizens of the United
States and I think it may be an undue
burden to have people have to go through
the Attorney General when people that
are not minorities they would consider
absurd to have to go to the attorney
general if they
were attacked coerced beaten tortured
threatened they would consider it absurd
to have to go to the attorney
general they would want that settle on
its own and I think this is a a good
move forward I I think we've done what
we could in the past and that was good
but I think we have to move forward and
I think if we don't do that what we're
doing is we're encouraging lawlessness
because of human nature if there's no
law if there's no punishment I'm going
to do more and if we look at the way
things are going right now people are
just seeing how much they can get away
with and so I think we need things in
place to say as a matter of fact
whatever we can do to make it better so
people people don't just ignore laws
because it comes down to that age-old
thing of the war on the weak people
think it's a war on brown and black
people or other minorities but it's
always been a war on the week and WW2
and should have taught us that sooner or
later it may start out with the Jews but
it gets around to everybody including
the French the Italian the Polish
Romanians and everybody else including
Germans so if we stop it at the
beginning it won't get to
us and that's my
comments thank you representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman is your
testimony relevant to HB
641 this this wasn't to me 641 because
we have a requirement that minorities
have to go through the Attorney General
in order to get some sort of recompense
that's a a burden to them whereas if
they could just file something
themselves and they should have the
rights of we should be moving so that
they have rights like everybody else so
I'm here to support this
bill any other
questions seeing none thank you
okay is there anyone else that wishes a
speak on house bills
641 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
641 and I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
620 yeah you
right and representative are you ready
do you have your witness you do okay
I'll recognize uh representative papichi
mu to introduce the bill
if it's okay I just want to wait a few
seconds for the movement to
subside for
ready thank you thank you Mr chairman
distinguished members of the committee I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
this bill for the record my name is
Daniel popovic mu I represent wiam
Rockingham 17 and um this is a
bipartisan bill that intends to protect
free speech in the uh in the during the
exercise of religious
beliefs to introduce the reason for it
at this point in time this right is
federally protected through the
religious freedom restoration act which
was passed in 1993 almost unanimously by
the Congress and Senate federally signed
in by President Clinton at a later point
the Supreme Court correctly ruled that
the compelling interest test that this
Federal legislation provides cannot be
enforced on the states unless they adopt
it themselves in New Hampshire we do
have a 2020 Supreme cour Court decision
in the state versus MAC that does that
that basically says that the compelling
interest test has to be used to burden
religious
exercise but I've never found it to be
good practice to rely on uh Court
precedence when legislation would do a
better job so the intent of HB 620 is to
code those protections the appropriate
level of protections into state law so
that we don't have to worry about the
Supreme Court potentially reversing
itself
it's actually a very short piece of
legislation I usually skip prefatory
Clauses but I felt that in this
particular case it was valuable to
briefly explain what the intent is it
may make it easier for courts to later
understand exactly the intent of the
language and really the entire meat of
the bill is on the bottom of page one
and the top of page two which says that
we have to use a compelling government
interest test and only the least
restrictive means
of furthering the compelling govern
governmental interest should be
used remedies are very basic and the
last part of the bill the construction
Clause is
really technically not needed because it
basically repeats what the
federal Clause says and we cannot really
overcome the supremacy clause makes them
theirs Prevail over hours but the intent
of putting it into the state legislation
is to clearly signal that we are not
trying to you know interfere with it in
any way
so this type of legislation has been
um adopted by a majority of the US
states quite a few other states that
have not adopted it are relying on their
Supreme Court existing decisions to not
adopt it but typically when it's passed
it tends to be passed with broad
bipartisan margins because everybody
agrees that you know it's a
constitutional right that needs to be
protected so I'm going to try to keep
this short and U I'll be happy to answer
any questions of course any
questions seeing none thank you oh
representative
Smith you're hiding behind
Joe well I'm always proud to be sitting
behind
Joe um thank you uh for being here um
can you uh relate the impact or import
might be a better word
of the proposed 620
FN on the use of
um uh public
money um
uh in uh religious
education I in my understanding of the
two areas of the laws I do not think
this has any practical impact on that
because again under
State versus MAC we already have that
decision by the Supreme Court so this
will not change the current practices it
will just enshrine the current state of
affairs into the you know state law
and I I genuinely don't see this as
impacting that directly because I don't
think we are sending you know State
money directly to any uh you know
religious organizations that would
create a legal issue here
any other questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Povich Mller uh I have
been looking at some of the online
testimony uh around this bill and I see
for example that we have testimony from
the American atheists organization in
opposition to HP 620 they assert that it
would somehow interfere with the
constitutional rights of uh New
Hampshire citizens um I I think they
might have say Granite State as they say
New Hampshire rights my question is
this can you see any possible
interpretation of this bill and of the
effect that it would produce which would
infringe upon anyone's constitutional
rights no I don't and frankly anybody
asserting that discretes constitutional
obligations must have not read the
Constitutions correctly because both the
Federal Constitution and the state
constitution clearly establish the
rights that this is protecting we are
just talking about a specific specific
judicial standard that has to be applied
which again has been established as the
correct one at every level of courts in
this country so I genuinely am a bit
confused as to what their concern is but
uh my cell phone is 6032 67 4142 if they
want to reach out to me I'll be happy to
address any concerns they may have thank
you thank you any other questions seeing
none thank you thank you
is it Lance
kimsey that right written testimony sure
yes provided a fairly large packet of
information maybe more than the
committee will have time to to look at
but my name is Lance kinzer um I
represent a group called First Amendment
partnership and uh my background with
riff roads that I had the opportunity
for six years to chair the house
Judiciary Committee in the state of
Kansas when we passed a rifra in 2013
and there's a story I'll get to in a
moment as to why we in particular Pastor
riffer in Kansas that I think is helpful
uh in understanding just how important
having Clarity with respect to the
standard of review in religious liberty
cases can be in fact in the Kansas
instance it was a matter of life and
death for one Jehovah's Witness woman
and I'll get back I'll come to that at
the conclusion of my remarks the the
representative already did a good job of
expressing the fact that uh unlike many
states the courts in New Hampshire have
been quite solicitous of protecting
religious liberty under the New
Hampshire Constitution and there's 2020
case state vmac in which the New
Hampshire Supreme Court was clear that
as they currently interpret the
constitution of state of Massachusetts
strict scrutiny the compelling State
interest test applies in cases where
there's a viol where there's a there's a
government action that substantially
burdens a sincerely held religious
belief and the way that your court
articulated that standard was that the
government must show a compelling State
interest and they must show that the
that the bill has been narrowly tailored
in order to achieve that interest what
you'll see in the bill is very similar
language but with a slightly but with
slightly different verbage and I want to
draw the committee's attention to that
because I think it is important uh to
recognize we're not trying to shift
anything here the least restrictive
means test and the narrow tailoring test
generally speaking are going to be
interpreted the same way in fact if at
some point the committee wanted to use
the Mac language and talk about narrow
tailoring instead of lease restrictive
means I don't think it would change it
if you look at the Mac opinion you'll
see that they actually site they
actually use least restrictive means
language as well in that opinion citing
favorably to another case and so my
point is to say those standards are the
same the representative already
mentioned that if you look at the bill
um towards the end there's a provision
that talks about construction and that
is when this was drafted the intent was
to try to make it look as close as
possible to the federal riff so that
there wasn't any kind of sense that we
were trying to hide the ball and act a
super rifra at a bunch of additional
protections a lot of States like
sticking very closely to the federal
language because there's 30 plus years
of stable precedent around how that's
been interpreted um but as the
representative noted that construction
clause which basically talks about the
fact that nothing in the bill can impact
the interpretation of The Establishment
Clause um in some ways is superflous
because of course nothing a state
legislature can do can impact the way
courts interpret a con a federal
constitutional provision so with all of
that said um let me return to the the
Kansas story and why I think Clarity on
this issue is so so important and why
having it in statute like 20 other eight
other states have done is important even
when you have pretty good case law in
Kansas we had pretty clear case law um
up through the early 90s uh that strict
scrutiny was the Constitutional standard
under our state Bill of Rights we then
had some dicta in a late 90s case that
created some confusion as to what
whether perhaps at least in some cases
the Smith rational basis test applied
and to step back I'm presuming a lot of
Baseline knowledge here but the reality
is that for
Generations um under the First Amendment
of the Constitution any time where there
was a substantial burden on religious
liberty the court would ask is there a
compelling governmental interest for
this action and has the government used
the least restrictive means to achieve
it if so even though there's a burden on
religious liberty the law stays in place
however um if those if those factors
aren't met uh then you don't get um you
don't get then you if those factors
aren't met then the state action is is
invalid and the plain if can Prevail so
in 1990 an Employment Division V Smith
for a wide array of um cases under
federal law the standard of proof was
shifted to rational basis essentially if
it's a if you get the rational basis
test you're almost always going to lose
I think any litigator would uh would
tell you that and so Congress uh passed
the religious freedom restoration act in
'93 signed by by President Clinton and
since then 28 states have passed their
own State rias making it clear that they
want the strict scrutiny standard now
what happened in Kansas going back to my
story we had a lack of clarity we had
somewhat confusing case law we didn't
have a state rifra and we had a
Jehovah's Witness woman who needed a a
she was a Medicaid recipient needed an
organ transplant and she was asking for
a religious waiver so she could go out
of state to have that procedure take
place in a way that comported with her
sincerely held religious beliefs around
blood transfusions there was a Medicaid
waiver board in Kansas promulgating our
state our State Medicaid RS and they
said no you don't get the waiver now
that was absurd there were all sorts of
things in the process that were broken
but Mary Stein Mets went through an
administrative hearing a district court
hearing and a Kan and and took her case
ultimately to the Kansas court of
appeals all because there was confusion
as to whether she got rational basis
review or strict scrutiny review and
ultimately um she won her case they said
that you should have been granted this
uh this waiver but by the time she had
finished doing all of that litigation
her situ her condition had so
deteriorated that she was no longer
eligible for the transplant list so in
2012 Mary Stein Mets died in the United
States of America for her sincerely held
religious belief and so the reason I'm
here all the way from Kansas despite
canceled flights a whole A real plane
trains and automobile story I could tell
about getting here just a couple minutes
before the hearing started um is because
I want to as much as I can I feel like
we in Kansas passing our riffer in 2013
a year after Mary Stein Mets died um
failed her and I want to communicate to
other states that just clarifying you're
already existing standard uh that your
courts have adopted would be a wise
thing to do a prudent thing to do and
ultimately will is a good thing for the
citizens of New Hampshire so I
appreciate the committee's Indulgence in
letting me speak for so long and I'd be
happy to answer questions
questions representative
Burch thank thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my will be in artfully
phrased questions and uh the compliment
that we're all as deeply versed in this
as you are because we're not um I
noticed in the bill the site to the
Flores case and perhaps you and I can
agree or can we agree that it's really
the Smith case that we're talking about
and the fact that the New Hampshire
Supreme Court um said that the New
Hampshire Constitution provides more
protections than the Smith case am I
correct so the Smith case is the the the
generating cause of of why we're here
today that's true the Flores case when
when riff was Tim initially passed at
the federal level the intent of Congress
was to have it apply to the states and
there was a little window in there from
93 to 97 where that was kind of the
understanding but that was test Ed in
this Flores case and the US Supreme
Court in a win for federalism said
Congress lacked the authority to impose
that on the states and so um you you got
a couple of you got a few states in the
90s right after um Employment Division V
Smith that that passed statutes and then
you get a pause because everybody
thought oh we don't even need it because
we have the federal riff and then a
bunch of States pass it post Flores
because it's clear the federal riffer is
not going to apply it state law followup
yeah okay so we have what is it the Mac
State ma H the peyot case and um I'm
wondering other than hey it's nice to
pass
legislation um is there any value added
in this
legislation to what the the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has already
said that article one part five yeah uh
provides what's the value added if
anything yeah so as someone who works on
religious liberty issues across the
country um Mac is a great opinion and
your current interpretation of your
state constitution applying strict
scrutiny
is there put it this way a number of
states even states that have passed
riffer relatively recently for example
Montana have done so despite the despite
or maybe in some ways even inspired by
or by the fact that they know that we've
got a long history of
interpreting our constitutional
Provisions in a way that's solicitous of
religious liberty and we want to make
sure that we lock that in as a statutory
matter so that there changes in the
composition of the courts um that that
standard is here and so in this instance
in some states where it's less clear
than New Hampshire I can I can see
somebody saying the need is more
pressing but my view is that having
Clarity on this issue by a reinforcing
statute is prudentially wise for states
to do because you don't know um how the
composition of the Court might change or
how might you might get a different
opinion in the future you know people
the feds didn't realize until the Smith
case happened that they needed a riffa
so
I just one follow up onee yeah quickly
go
yeah but what I hear from you is that
life doesn't change if we pass this
tomorrow for the next day and the next
day
but you suggest that the protection of a
statute might protect against the future
New Hampshire Supreme Court my question
is if a future New Hampshire Supreme
Court thinks uh Max wrongly decided the
fact that we have a statute won't make
okay this is a great question because it
leads to an issue that sometimes is a
little bit
confusing the legislature can't just
like Congress couldn't tell the US
Supreme Court the New Hampshire
legislature can't tell the state supreme
court how to
interpret the Constitution that's the
perview of the court but what the what A
legislature can do what the federal
riffer did and what this bill would do
is it can create an independent
statutory protection that is parallel to
or in some instances like at the federal
level broader so this wouldn't change
and it wouldn't direct the the courts of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court to
interpret the Constitution any
differently than it does now because
that's their prerogative but it would
say that you could as a New Hampshire
citizen bring both a claim under the
State Constitution and you could bring
your statutory claim which is an
independent right and so um it's
different in that sense that you would
have both of those claims and if you
know for years and years we could have
been sitting in you know in Congress in
' 89 and somebody could have said we
have sherbet V verer why do we need this
you know this riffer bill um to protect
our rights and I think the person
sitting there would have said what I
said we we don't know when we may get a
contrary opinion and having an
independent statutory right protects our
citizens against that eventuality so it
it but it conceptually it is a a
statutory right not a constitutional
right to preserve the separation of
powers thank you representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for traveling here and and uh
offering us this testimony
today as I consider this
bill one of the the elements that I see
is that
religion uh is not explicitly defined by
the new language in the bill although it
does make reference to
uh the New Hampshire state constitution
part one articles four and five which of
course include uh language uh talking
about one's right to worship God in the
manner and season most agreeable to the
dictates of One's Own conscience and so
forth if I
know that there are uh a good number of
people and organizations in our society
today who act in the manner of a
religion with regard to uh topics like
Dei and climate
change and if I know that the federal
refer act also does not define
religion can you articulate what you
perceive should be interpreted If This
Were passed as a religious belief and
how you might view certain other beliefs
as being other than religious beliefs so
that's a a great question and it's not
an easy one in some ways and one of the
reasons that the bill doesn't attempt a
statutory definition of religion and
instead defaults to the way in which the
term religion has been interpreted in
constitutional documents is because um
any any attempt to Define religion in a
a Webster's Dictionary kind of way in a
statute runs the risk of either being
overly or underly inclusive and so
the the ability to look at the facts and
circumstances of a given case to
determine whether based upon all the the
background and case law that there is
around this question of what is a
religion whether it applies we just
think that caseby casee determination is
the better way to go as opposed to
trying to Define it in the statute what
I will say is this that courts have been
very leery uh to question a religious
belief based upon the fact of you know
do we agree with it do we disagree with
it is it rational is it irrational but
what courts will evaluate often times is
is this
belief sincerely held is it sincerely
religious and so courts actually are
quite good um at and I think New
Hampshire courts would be as well they
at faring out kind of pretext religion
claims and so religion typically is more
than a mere philosophical belief
um and and but um I I guess I'll just
leave it there to say no State Rios
attempt
a blackl definition of religion because
it really has to be determined based
upon the facts and circumstances of a
given
individual thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much
Peter
Chamberlain thank you so much I'm Peter
Chamberlain I Pastor the granite state
Baptist Church right here in conquer and
so I'm not here as a lawyer to be able
to defend those those are interesting
questions which we could answer from our
perspective on uh religion but we're
asking in support of this bill simply
because we know that the Constitution
does give freedom of
religion but to have this clarified that
any laws or anything that is imposed
upon any church synagogue or religious
gathering um not just be a blanket
statement this does not just give us
cart Blan to do whatever we would like
to do but actually have this defined
that if a law is going to be imposed or
restrictions upon a church or assembly
that yes it is proven this is in the
best interest and then okay we have the
defense is what you're requiring
actually the most um minimal invasive
way to be able to apply that and so to
be able to separate that now to go back
to one question on making this statutory
instead of Precedence when it comes from
the Supreme Court and basing it upon
their judgment I do go back to the
scriptures and uh the book of Exodus
reminds us that uh there was a pharaoh
there was a king that arose that knew
not
Joseph and everything changed from the
previous generation because it was
subjective and now they interpreted
things completely different and so when
we are in a society that a law can be
subjective that it can change
interpretation we would rather have
something codified in law that clearly
defines uh exactly what the parameters
are and not B in it upon just the
opportunity uh to go back and
reinterpret what a precedent would be or
something that was put forth and so to
help clarify in your mind about religion
and this is from our perspective when we
do go to scripture uh James does the
Book of James does Define that very well
pure religion and undefiled before God
is to visit the fatherless and the
widows and to keep himself unspotted
from the world now in Christianity when
we hold to the scripture ures uh we
believe that that also not more than
just a philosophical belief but actually
having actions behind that so I believe
it would have to be a sincere belief
that causes actions and has an outflow
not just hold up in a room somewhere
saying I believe this therefore give me
all the benefits and so there has to be
a sincerely held belief and also an
outward acting on those beliefs to be
able to make a difference in those that
are around so that's why we as a church
I have uh two other pastors were not
able to be here and so combined we would
be representing just in our three
between four and 500 people that we
could March through asking for this to
be codified and support the bill and uh
several others you say why is a man come
from Kansas to be able to help he is
here with us we are in um Fellowship
over this and uh to be able to discern
that a little bit more so from our
perspective as a pastor and our church
we are asking for support of the bill to
be able to codify this just Define it
and will it change anything tomorrow no
but it may help things not to change for
our next Generation that's coming and uh
to be able to protect that and that's
what we're after so thank you very much
for the time if there are any questions
from a pastor's perspective I'll be
happy to answer them for you any
questions seeing none thank you
wonderful Timothy chavalia
good afternoon my name is Timothy Shaler
I'm an attorney here in Conquer New
Hampshire live in Lowden have four kids
I've had the privilege of studying
constitutional law extensively in law
school and in continued education
programs as a lawyer and one thing I've
seen is that many times people that are
the plaintiffs or defendant in these
cases are law-abiding citizens who
suddenly get a spot of conflict between
the the government and the religion and
they're trying to reconcile it so on a
practical level how do we help those
people resolve those problems and how do
we do it efficiently you know if someone
calls me as an attorney and asks me
about constitutional law how do you
interpret that what might they do let's
read through this big MA case let's try
to guess it gets pretty complicated and
that makes it more expensive and that's
a barrier to resolving these things
efficiently so I think if we have a
statute that lays something out clearly
that someone's in this troubled
situation can open the statute said
here's the law it's clear they can go
through a process to solve it it can
help us to get through those difficult
situations
and as a society I think we do want to
accommodate people who may see things
different than us I think that's a a
strength of our society that diversity
there's also Val have a process to do
that because ideals are just ideals
until you have a way to work through
those problems and I think this helps
work through those problems so I thank
you for considering this if you have
questions I'm happy to answer them any
questions seeing none thank
you SAR Burke Cohen
my colleague Brody just is GNA join me
at the table um if that's okay with you
chair okay see that one more time I
didn't you didn't go over the mic so do
you mind if Brody just says my partner
just that's fine all right thank you sir
um my name is Sarah Burke Cohen I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um the New Hampshire
Municipal Association sorry if I'm not
talking to that straightly uh opposes
this bill uh we feel that this bill has
several issues that could present
themselves um part of those issues um
were uh brought forward in actually the
city of War versus flues where um a
church was attempting to was in a
historic district and looking to um get
an extension onto it and was denied that
permit and went up to the Supreme Court
as we know um um and the federal rifra
was um found to be unconstitutional as
it applied to states that the the
Federal Constitution didn't reach to
States um the New Hampshire Municipal
association's biggest concern is that
similar to um what has happened in uh
the city of Bourne uh that uh religious
institutions could use um the compelling
uh interest um test to expand and use
that so that they would um be able to
uh make a claim that they wouldn't have
to uh follow uh normally neutral uh laws
such as um zoning or uh similar
ordinances although there although there
is is the state court uh the Supreme
Court test uh that has been put forward
we think that uh having it in the
statute uh would again open up for
possible abuse for for these neutral um
tests it also uh could uh cause
discrimination as you know against
marginalized people we also have some
some um you know unintended consequences
I think um representative McFarland
asked about the definition of religious
or religious beliefs that is not settled
this could uh create um complex
litigation that involves um this statute
including trying to Define what a
religious or religious belief is um it
also could include complex litigation
relative to what is a compelling
interest what is Al tailored means these
as uh the attorney that uh just
testified can be costly and would be
costly for municipalities who are
attempting to enforce their uh local
zoning ordinances or otherwise uh
neutral neutrally applicable laws um
with that are there any questions for me
representative
mcfallen thank you Mr chairman I I just
had a question on your commentary there
about the perspective uh potential for
emerging legislation along the lines of
the question I had asked earlier and I'm
I must admit perplexed by your comments
in light of the fact that we have had
the the current language in our state
constitution for quite a long time and I
don't recall any such legislation
perhaps you can expand upon why you
think this would suddenly precipitate
that I'm talking about this legislation
that there is potential for if suits
were brought claims were made under this
this specific legislation that it could
create complex legis uh complex suits
involving trying to Define religion
trying to Define religious beliefs
trying to Define what a compelling
interest would be and trying to Define
what narrowly tailored means means
follow up means follow
up let me see if I can ask the question
more
simply anyone seeking to bring such a a
a set of
claims would they not have already been
able to bring similar claims against uh
you know based on our constitution for
as long as that's been around I must be
missing
something relative to claims under for
freedom of exerc free exercise of
religion well I assume people have
brought claims under free exercise for
religion under the New Hampshire
Constitution thank
you representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I guess you you brought up
something I didn't even think about are
you saying
that a violate like a zoning ordinance
that violates somebody's free exercise
of religion would allow them the
opportunity to sue the town in violation
of their freedom of religion under this
bill so you can start but yeah um so as
I was talking about the city of Bourne
versus Flores um part of what
so the area where the the um religious
institution was the church was was a
historic district they applied to get a
building permit to extend their church
it was
denied um they made a claim under the
federal rra saying that the denial of
the permit violated their free exercise
uh of religion um that decision was
never
you know never made so to speak because
the the the Supreme new Hamp uh
Hampshire the United States Supreme
Court found that it couldn't apply to
States right um so that that is a
concern is that the these types of cases
zoning cases where it's a neutral uh a
neutrally applicable zoning
law under this new statute and uh an
entity could get denied a permit and
bring a claim under this statute thank
you that was great information for me
and very helpful thank
you representative
bur I want to go back and revisit for a
moment the the problem of lack of
definition of religion or religious
practice and whether you think it's
necessary in a bill such as that this
because and it's my question two of the
three court cases were talking about the
New Hampshire case and the Smith case
both had to do with the question of
whether the use of peyote which was
banned by a law of General
applicability our criminal law or
whatever state it was criminal laws uh
balanced against the religious needs and
whether the use of peyote claimed to be
for religious purposes and and I'm not
the one to decide whether it was or not
is that problematic in a bill such as
this when there's no mention at all
about laws of General applicability in
terms of the
balance can you rephrase your question
I'm it's yeah moving around in my head
the ba the balance referred to in in
like the Smith case uh had to do with
you've got laws of general applicability
and then you've got uh specific
religious
claims and in doing the balance there's
a standard of uh compelling State
interest uh least restrictive in
ETC but if there's
already no definition of religious or
religion and there's no mention in here
in the bill
of the whole concept of laws of General
applicability is that
problematic am I any clear I would say
that again I think this goes back to
um how riffa could be used right um you
are correct there isn't anything in here
about laws um laws of General
applicability um nor is there definition
of religion I think this goes back to
the complexity of legal actions that
could could in fact take place under
this under this uh proposed um bill that
it would o this bill is Broad enough
that it would allow for an it to become
more complex at the time right you have
general laws of
applicability and there's no definition
of religious religion or religious
beliefs um so I think that would just
amount to more complex and more time
consuming um
litigation any other questions seeing
none thank
you David
Trumble thank thank you Mr chairman my
name is David Trumble I'm from the town
of where um I just come with some basic
questions and concerns about the bill uh
going back to when the federal law was
first passed with broad support uh it
was seen as a way to make sure that
everybody could fre freely exercise
their own religions and at that point in
time I think we had as a society a
pretty common understanding that there
was a hard line between free exercise
and The Establishment Clause that the
government was not in in any way
supposed to be helping to establish
religions there was a a test the lemon
test would said
that any assistance to religions had to
be done solely or primarily for secular
purposes so I would you know certainly
support uh they're not being laws that
would stop people from exercising their
freedom of religion I just wanted to go
to the question that was raised by
representative Smith which was about
what about financial assistance from the
government um because I think that's the
the next area that's concerned and so
the question is what if that the
government has a program that has direct
assistance and religion wants to access
that direct assistance as I understand
the uh answer from the prime sponsor he
indicated that that was not a problem
because uh we're not giving any money
directly to religious schools right now
so just and and he also said he thought
that the construction statute was not
really needed so I just want to be clear
because the construction statute says
that granting government funding to the
extent permissible Under The
Establishment Clause shall not
constitute a violation of this chapter
so in other words that the government
would be allowed to give money to
religions to do things to the extent
permissible Under The Establishment
Clause so as long as everybody is in
agreement that that means if what the
church is doing is primarily for a
secular purpose and not to promote its
religious purposes then that would be uh
consistent with the understanding that
goes way back to what we understood in
1990s when the federal law was passed so
because otherwise you would run up
against serious problems in New
Hampshire we have a
constitutional um provision against
money going to religious schools you
have a lot of civil rights issues
involved that would involve civil rights
not being applied at religious schools
so I just wanted to make sure that that
as I was listening to this that it's the
understanding of the legislature that
this is not um this this is to stop as
the Pastor said is to stop laws that
would impose and restrict somebody's
freedom of practicing their religion
it's not meant to authorize the
government to fund religion I just want
to make sure that that was issue was
brought up and that there was
understanding on that thank you
sir any
questions no seeing none thank you thank
you that's the last card I have on House
Bill 620 is there anyone else here that
wants to speak on this bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
620 and we have one minute before the
next one so if you want to stand up and
stretch grab lunch
something
e
e e
okay now that I sent everyone away for
break we're going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 633 and I
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Daniels to introduce the
bill thank you Mr chairman uh number one
did you want to change this yeah we have
no it's not oh it is it is accurate
what's up somebody took care of it
already the back side might not be all
right the other side is good the camera
is this way yeah we'll see uh Mr
chairman uh if if it's okay could I also
ask uh Mr M Michael Delano to join me
sure thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Gary Daniels I'm a representative from
Hillsboro District 43 representing the
town of Milford I'm also Prime sponsor
of House Bill
633 uh bipartisan bill that seeks a
private sector solution to the housing
crisis through the use of housing invest
Investment Trust New Hampshire faces a
significant housing crisis with high
rental costs and expensive home prices
leading to a shortage of affordable
homes for working families and an and an
expected deficit of 60,000 units by 2030
now I've always contended that I
personally don't have the answers to all
of the challenges before us but I've
always contended that by working
together we may find those Solutions in
my last two terms as Senate Finance
chair I recognized that we were pouring
hundreds of thousands of dollars into
efforts to find a private sector excuse
me a public sector solution to
affordable housing yet the problem
continued to
grow it therefore was intriguing to me
when Michael del aano contacted me to
discuss the idea of a private sector
solution to housing an in ative idea
that does not use taxpayer money not
only could we contribute to a solution
to the housing crisis but we could do it
without adding to the state budget an
added advantage to this legislature as
it faces the state budgeting
challenges the housing Investment Trust
a
501c3 charity addresses this issue by
utilizing private Investments to acquire
properties and provide families with
flexible
financing options the trust operations
involve purchasing and rehabilitating
homes expanding the housing Supply and
increasing state tax revenues the loan
revolving Loan Fund supports these
efforts by allowing Capital investors to
fund housing projects with repayments
revolving back into the fund the trust
is governed by a board of directors and
trustees ensuring the achievement of
charitable goals
and the fair treatment of beneficiaries
ultimately promoting home ownership
wealth accumulation Community
Development and job creation Mr chairman
whereas Mr Delano is the architect of
this proposal which he has been
developing over the course of a year
with your concurrence I'd like to turn
this over to him now for more specified
explanation of the housing Investment
Trust I hope the committee will be open
to this inov ative approach to
addressing the housing shortage with a
private sector solution and take the
first step by voting an ought to pass
recommendation on House Bill 633 this
concludes my testimony thank you Mr
chairman thank you yes you can go ahead
if anyone has questions for either one
of them afterwards who can ask them then
you all okay thank you for your time my
name is Michael Delano I'm Amherst New
Hampshire um let me Begin by saying I am
not an attorney um even though a lot of
the work in front of you looks like it
was drafted by an
attorney um I do have over 50 years of
real estate experience and beginning
undergraduate work in community planning
with a second degree in housing and have
developed it built it owned it managed
it over the 50 years very familiar with
the topic of Real Estate 6 house bille
633 simply asked the legislature to add
the definition of a housing Investment
Trust to RSA
293b um and to wave the fees normally
associated with uh entities chartered
under
293b um I've provided the committee with
uh information on HP 633 which allows
the members to look at the trust
structure as well as to read about its
functions and features and among those
um HP 633 establishes a housing
Investment Trust as a 501c3 Strat uh
charity its purpose is to ease uh New
Hampshire's housing crisis one goal is
to offer stable affordable housing
options that attract and settle working
wage householders in support of New
Hampshire's
employers the trust will operate as a
privately funded initiative uh to expand
and preserve the supply of affordable
housing in New Hampshire um that that
state desperately needs to act as a
magnet for younger working wage families
enabled under
293b the trust manages a series of
subsidiary trusts that buy and renovate
if needed uh Workforce housing units
funded by private donations and income
qualified investors each subsidiary
trust in the series will own one
property title and um or a long-term
tency rights to a rental unit or an ad
you um and holding these rights enables
the trust to maintain the affordability
of that unit for multiple families and
the economic model is really Simply
Built on the fact that one investment in
one property serves many
families and the trust financing
structure was designed um to draw
talented
uh young families looking for career
opportunities and to build wealth so
that they can move out of these homes
and buy their own
home uh the trust will offer governance
funding and counseling support to
householders Across the state um with
that I'm happy to take your questions
are there any questions representative
Oregon um it says there's no State uh
taxes or revenues but um if it's a 501c3
would these properties be subject to to
property tax it seems like or would they
be exempt from property tax well it's
interesting you asked that we had
discussions just on that matter uh with
the I'm sorry yes we we discussed this
with the Department of Revenue last week
and um they think that um on a Town
Bytown basis uh would be a determination
because the way it's my walk away
Takeaway on it was that every year a
form needs to be filled out uh asking
for an exemption which is pretty
honorous if we are spread across the
state different towns so it's unlikely
that we'll go after any kind of
charitable deduction unless there is a
charitable purpose that demands that
kind of treatment and that's based on
who sponsors the
home right if the town for example wants
to uh sponsor a home in the trust uh
it's their prerogative whether they
collect taxes on it or not but they'll
tell
US Representative Perez you thanks for
taking my question this is way above my
pay grade I was a nurse for 42 years so
I have two quick questions first of all
do you have investors lined up already
that are interested in this
well right now it's way too early to
solicit money um the process that we're
going through is to establish this in
law and over the next summer work with
the attorneys to fill in the gaps and
answer all the questions like the tax
question that just came up so um I am
starting to get investment calls I got
calls just yesterday from Wellington
Management which is a well-known fund uh
asking me how much money we need so
there's an awful lot of capital out
there chasing opportunity but we're not
ready to accept it second question
quickly go ahead my concern is about big
conglomerates coming in and buying up
and being part of this from out of state
and that's my concern is there going to
do you anticipate any regulations around
maintaining it
as I
mean whatever your concern is
well-founded
um we're asking the governor to appoint
uh the board of director s and the
trustees uh and to establish this as a
public private cooperation or
collaboration where the state will have
their finger on the steering wheel but
it'll be a privately funded organization
running it just to avoid the situation
that you're talking
about representative
Smith thank you very much um I I need
help I don't understand understand where
the money is going to come from why if
this
is a good
idea would
someone contribute to this rather than
just go and do exactly what you're
asking out there in the free
market great question
um you know when people say it's a great
question question I'm always curious
about what they mean well it it for my
it to to me it means uh your perception
of the situation is Right On Target
it's the question that you're answering
is who gets what and when and the
capital investors out there now are
looking for double-digit returns and
they're not getting any they're willing
to accept market rate returns for
example mortgage bonds
uh when Banks originate mortgages and
they sell them to the secondary Market
those are packaged and sold to investors
earning earning rates that are driven by
the market that are in the range of
something just less than the mortgage
rates um and that those are the
investors that we would be looking for
that want an a return on and return of
investment that is fair but this is also
a socially responsible investment so you
have a whole cohort of investors that do
nothing but invest in this kind of thing
the structure is set up so that it
conforms with the 1940s Investment Trust
act which is federal legislation
293b the state statute RSA is the
state's enablement to allow companies
and organizations in New Hampshire to
operate under the 1940s Investment Trust
act the Investment Trust Act is what uh
ETFs and mutual funds and re
operate under and the point being is
that if we can get an up up running
prototype that this is scalable to
attract money nationally through things
like mutual funds uh that would socially
responsible mutual funds that would take
a return on investment that is
commensurate with what we can afford to
pay I hope that answers your
question if not try again
I recognize your good faith in answering
um it answers my question it doesn't
satisfy my concerns you if I may please
fire away I what your concern is
followup okay okay representative
McFarland thank you thank you Mr
chairman so I I I have to to use um
representative Smith's term concerns
that I would like to clarify your intent
with you
on first of all and I know we already
touched on the question of If This Were
to pass this is what the statutory
impact might be on property tax but if
we talk about
intent would you agree that it would be
wholly wrong for these trusts holding
residential property not to pay property
tax TR not let me sure if I understand
your question you're asking my opinion
on whether the intent is to set it up as
a charity to avoid
taxation uh I I let me rephrase what I'm
asking as I'm asking the intent of the
Prime sponsor and yourself with regard
to to whether your expectation is that
even with these vehicles in
place would you not agree
that we should see property taxes being
paid on these houses I think so uh all
the numbers build in the property tax at
the fair market value based on advolum
taxation follow up follow up
so why then and and and I appreciate all
the words that you have
spoken but I I'm maybe I'm um tired this
afternoon I I I guess I am not
understanding why this is something that
should be the subject of a charitable
organization rather than a conventional
trust oh certainly
um you need to understand first off is
that it isn't what the property is worth
that matters it's what the trust pays
for it the lower the cost of the
property the more effective the trust
can be to serve the target
audience it's a charity one of the
primary reasons it's a charity is the
concept of a bargan sale and bargain
sale under is rules allows a homeowner
in this case to sell their property to
the
trust and take at a a price below its
market value and take a charitable
donation in lie of cash so let me give
you an example if you had somebody who
had a million dollar home and their
basis was half a million dollars they
would have a capital gain on that half a
million in excess of their basis at a
20% tax bracket they would have a tax of
$100,000 in a very rough numbers and of
course the CPAs would have to work with
the donor if they had sold that home to
the trust at
900,000 they would get a tax deduction
for 100,000 and walk away with the same
amount of money but without having to
pay a tax but the trust would be
beneficiary of a property at a lower
price which we could then um subdivide
into multiple units to expand the
housing Supply so is that kind of
mechanism that we're trying to leverage
with the charitable
basis thank
you representative B rbo then
representative B you can you tell us
thank you for taking my question can you
tell us how this has worked elsewhere uh
or if this structure has been deployed
uh in other jurisdictions how it's
worked or what what problems may have
Arisen most of the uh
reasonable um fact similes of this use
real estate investment trusts and what
they call shared Equity Arrangements
where the Real Estate Investment Trust
buys the land and the homeowner buys the
improvements above the land and finances
them in fact FHA has a whole program on
on land trust model uh financing where
um they will accept the ground rent or
the ground the ground lease as a basis
for long-term
debt um so I spent a lot of time with um
the folks that developed the Burlington
Land Trust model um and the the
attorneys that helped them craft that
back years ago when I first
started um one of the problems that that
model has is Property Management over
that single family home and a
distributed environment became very
problematic for them and that's why you
typically see Land Trust models are
clustered like in Burlington
Vermont um what this gives us is the
opportunity to have
independently operated trusts each
subsidiary trust is it is its own uh
entity with its own tax reporting it
does a couple of things it allows um
what we call directed investment so if
an employer or a hospital wanted to
invest in some of these homes for nurses
they could directly invest in specific
units and so the the structure we're
giving gives us the flexibility to have
multiple classes of investors as well as
directed investors employers can invest
in a particular unit that's close to
their place of
work guess I'm asking has that been done
in other places and how is it how has it
succeeded I'm sorry I didn't quite
you're describing for instance that
nurses or the employer wanting to invest
in you know one of the sub trusts for
the employees how has that worked out in
other instances you talked about the
property management concerns right that
with the land trust that you
described I'm just I'm just looking for
more feedback on the experience of
working with the structure there is
nothing out there that operates the way
this structure is set up okay it is set
up though taking the best parts of the
models that are out there and creating a
unique environment for a first
internation opportunity for New
Hampshire thank
you representative Burch first and
then thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
for uh for taking my questions I'm
trying to figure out some of the tax
consequences or whether this is how much
of this is simply at some level uh uh a
tax
avoidance system in terms of what towns
or the state collects in terms of real
estate taxes so if I understand um this
uh this
rlf uh
buys a an existing home from somebody
and there's some benefits to the seller
by using the
charitable um tax rate instead of the
regular tax rate to put it in elegantly
but as you described 100,000 and you
wouldn't have to pay as many much taxes
uh capital gains and then the
rlf sits there and and tries to fill
that house with a homeowner the
homeowner is GNA pay the real estate
taxes the utilities and everything else
but doesn't have ownership in
it perhaps at some point the rlf sells
that property to an
individual and presumably there's a t
that generates a taxable event yeah yeah
I'm getting lost here who pays what
taxes so first first of all the
revolving Loan Fund is a separate
for-profit organization that we have no
control
over it is a funding
mechanism the
charity the housing Investment
Trust relies on the revolving Loan Fund
as a funding source okay it's an arms
lent transaction they do not hold title
to any of the trust property however
they do have collateral
um beneficial interests in the trust
property as a lender would normally have
okay
so in terms of Taxation on the revolving
Loan Fund um whatever they would pay in
taxes they're going to
pay um in terms of Taxation with the the
trust uh there would be no uh business
Enterprise tax because it is a charity
uh but
you know transfer taxes and such would
all be paid in in the um operation of
acquiring and
selling uh the properties that the trust
controls does
that and that would be paid at a normal
taxable rate or is there some different
rate if a charity is buying or selling
well I think what you're going to find
over the course of the year and and
conversation with the attorneys that
we're going to use to structure this is
that uh the transfer tax on an exchange
of
property um would
be that portion of the property that the
householder purchases so the trust owns
the property has title whatever taxes
are paid to own the property in the
trust that's done so now what the trust
does is it has a householder that comes
in and acquires a beneficial interest in
that specific trust and it's like seller
financing the trust provides them with a
loan to acquire that beneficial interest
now that acquisition is a transfer of
beneficial interest which is taxable and
on the back end when that property sells
is a transfer of beneficial interest
that is collected again
um what we're hoping to see is that they
pay a transfer tax on the portion of
beneficial interest that they acquire
not a tax on the entire value of the
property but we're not sure just yet if
how that mechanism will work so taxes
will be paid in hopefully in proportion
to what they
own thank you representative McFarland
just following up on representative
Rambo's line of questioning so can you
explain to
me uh You' you've painted a picture of
certain scenarios um where we we are
supposed I think
to infer a social good but you've also
painted a picture where for example you
have a hospital using this as script
housing for their
Workforce you've painted a picture where
um the the housing units could remain
within this housing Investment Trust for
a long period of
time are you not by create by by you
know submitting this pill are you not
submitting something that is going to
distort the marketplace for other
builders and are you suggesting that in
your hospital
example uh the the hospital would make
the property available uh at at you know
a fair market rent
to all comers or or just to their own
staff
well first of all your your question
about Market
Distortion um a 100 homes is going to
cost us $50 million a th000 homes will
cost us 5 billion at a median price of
$500,000 obviously not every house in
the state is worth 500,000 but give or
take a few billion dollars so there's an
economy of scale here that we are very
unlikely we got 640,000 units in the
state th000 units is not going to
distort anything um what the purpose of
this is is to provide a steady inventory
of Workforce housing that is available
on a regular basis to multiple families
in 2008 when I worked with the housing
authority to craft the uh Workforce
housing uh documentation that was used
uh when the bill first came out
uh we never imagined that these homes
that were allowed under um 674
58 um would be um capitalized on by
buyers you go find a Workforce housing
unit that was allowed by law uh and try
and buy it today and so the problem one
of the problems that we're trying to
solve here is to hold that unit for its
intended purpose and I'm not saying
they'll be held forever the trust can
sell them if the municipality for
example says to us here's an example
municipality under 674 allows Workforce
housing as part of a development we're
asking that we'll be asking that
municipality to sell us that home at the
price set by the Housing
Authority now assuming we buy it and now
we'll hold that to that price as long as
admin IP ality who allowed that house to
be built they have covidence on it they
say 20 years well at the end of 20
years we can dispose of that property
and any profit that's made on that would
go be circulated back into buying more
affordable housing so our intent is not
to lock down and create some private
rent control but rather to preserve the
housing stock so that we could serve as
many families as possible with that
entry level price the whole purpose here
is to get a home occupied at an
entry-level price and make subsequent
buyers make that available to subsequent
buyers at the same price that the first
buyer had so we're not looking to raise
the price there is zero Equity
appreciation built into the numbers
everything is assumed that it's our
basis is our basis and every subsequent
buyer will have the opportunity to buy
at that basis one of the other problems
that's happening right now is because of
the mortgage rate homes that have been
purchased under the workforce housing
law at low interest rates are now trying
to sell those Homes at a higher interest
rate and the capitalized value of that
home is less than what they paid for it
even though they bought it as a
Workforce housing unit in this situation
they don't hold title to the property so
if they want to leave all they have to
do is give us 30 days notice and we give
them a check for their builtup Equity
the purpose being is to be able to get
them into a position where they can grow
roots in the community take jobs grow
wealth sufficient so that they have a
nest egg that they can invest in their
own property in that community and then
bring another family and at the same
basis does that address your
question uh I I appreciate the answer I
think I have the answer that I need um I
don't know whether it addresses my
question thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you
is there anyone else that wants to speak
on House Bill
633 seeing none I'll close the hearing
on House Bill 633 and we have about 15
minutes before the next
hearing
e
e e
okay I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill
611 and recognize representative shur to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chair um I I've been
encouraged ened in in the most important
ways to be as quiet as quick as possible
so thank you I know this is your last
bill of the day so as a law professor
it's against all my instincts to not
talk
forever uh my name is representative bu
sure I'm rep represent Portsmouth W 3
Rockingham District
26 uh and uh I'm here to save the state
money
uh it's very rare that I get to say that
um so what we're talking about is uh the
something called the recruitment statute
I'll give you a very brief overview of
the recruitment statute uh many years
ago uh uh the legislature passed a bill
that said uh when somebody is appointed
a public defender or a private court
appointed lawyer the state has uh the
state sh shall recoup money uh from uh
that person at a uh a set fee A reduced
fee um um it is for at least at one
point it was around $800 for a
misdemeanor uh so it didn't and that
money that was recouped went into the
general fund it didn't go to the
Indigent defense fund uh it didn't it
wasn't a mechanism for funding uh
Indigent defense Services it just went
into the general fund uh and what would
happen What originally happened is the
the um
uh an individual who wanted a courta
appointed lawyer would file a financial
affidavit usually at arraignment the
judge would look at the financial
affidavit appoint a lawyer and then look
at the financial affidavit to decide
whether to send the case to the office
of Cost Containment which is a a uh
office that's a part of the Department
of administrative Services uh that
process was essentially Auto relatively
automatic um and um and so uh and as a
part of that process uh it was also the
case that uh the that occurred at the
beginning of the case which meant that
even if somebody were found not guilty
on all the charges or all the charges
were dismissed they would still recuit
they would still recruit money um
several years ago about uh five or six
years ago now uh this this committee and
the legislature made changes uh to the
recruitment process it said uh from now
on we're not going to rec recoup money
from people who have been found not
guilty in all the charges or had all the
charges dismissed number one and number
two we're going to move the moment that
the judge makes a determination as to
whether to send the case to the office
of Cost Containment for recruitment uh
to the sentencing
hearing um and what has happened is that
judges have I've talked to a number of
Judges about this what has happened is
judges have said what effectively said
to themselves well I'm finding this
person
$500 I'm um uh I'm perhaps in that case
ordering a restitution
and I'm going to take another look at
the updated financial affidavit it
doesn't make any sense for me to be also
ordering recruitment uh as a financial
matter once judges started looking at
individual cases on a case-by Case basis
they really in large num stop stopped
sending cases to the office of Cost
Containment thereby the large reduction
in the amount of money that the office
of Cost Containment is has been
collecting
um at I I think the um
um the financial note uh describes uh
where we are now um and I know the
director of administrative Services uh
and uh a person very familiar with the
office of Cost Containment will be
testifying after me uh and explaining in
more detail uh some uh
some things that we might want to add to
this legislation so that the the end of
the office of Cost Containment can
happen quickly and as painlessly as
possible uh with that I'll take any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you oh we
have one here representative Burch so am
I correct in saying two things one
that the cost of collection is going up
the amount recouped is going down and
secondly that the cost of collection is
more than is being
recouped the second is true the first is
not true in this way I think back before
the changes were made about five or six
years ago the cost of collection was
around 600
$600,000 the cost of collection is now
because there's so much less being
collected the the resources you don't
need as many resources so the cost of
collection has gone down to 380,000 uh
this past year but yes the cost of cost
the amount collected is less than the
cost of collection now
any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Katherine Keane and Charlie is it
Arling house Arling
house like darling was a D in a house on
the end um was my grandmother's line uh
I'm Charlie Arling housee I'm the
commissioner of administrative Services
hi I'm Cassie Keenan the Deputy
Commissioner of Das um so for the record
we're technically not in favor or
opposed to this bill I told the
governor's office because as you
probably know I can't testify for or
against anything without direct written
permission of Major League Baseball um
we're here providing information I will
note that our budget as presented in the
Govern phase does not include an office
of Cost Containment starting on July 1st
2026 so you might guess that I can see
which way the wind is blowing um
uh just to put it in perspective seven8
years ago we collected 2.5 million which
goes into the general fund and is in the
other line in Revenue this year we'll
collect about 300,000 so think of that
line is going down and the line of
collections has been a little bit bumpy
but flattish and it went down a bit uh
when those two lines cross it's like in
Ghostbusters you're not supposed to
cross the lines and so we cross the line
so it's time for things to um move on um
a couple of thoughts though if if you
are going to eliminate the office of
Cost Containment the bill has an
effective date of January 1st I think it
would be sensible to have an effective
date upon upon passage um I'm
uncomfortable with the idea of a
limbo um where there is a um a period of
time where it's been repealed but not
effective yet because you're you're
Dunning somebody for for $10 a week that
he's not going to have to keep paying in
about a month or too and it's awkward to
say the least um I'm going to suggest to
the sponsor language just a sentence
along the lines of the commissioner
shall be authorized to um take whatever
reasonable measures to wind the office
down as Mak sense um I I would propose
that secondly um our our understanding
of the bill is that upon passage we
should stop collecting we have two kinds
of collections one is if a judge happens
to assign a new case it doesn't happen
Much
Anymore um but it does happen
periodically um the other kind is there
are people who are paying $5 a week or
something like that a month for and have
been for years and and they continue to
pay our presumption is that when this is
repealed everybody stops paying and
which I think is reasonable and fair and
helps the state avoid lawsuits and so I
so I would tell you that that is Our
intention we hope the effective date
will be upon passage we hope that um we
can have some sort of proformer language
about we can take whatever measures um
and we hope uh and and we hope our
understanding is correct about about
that we should stop collecting on on
everyone then the fourth thing I would
suggest is that we be directed to
destroy all the
records um I know that sounds weird
although if you'd seen the Clutter that
is state government where the paper
never goes away um it's a good thing but
there are records sometimes that we're
we're required to keep for like seven
years well we're we end a program and
we're not really going to go back in six
months and say you know what Fred um
we're going to start collecting from you
again I think it would be reasonable to
have me um shred everything just to just
so it also avoids the possibility of uh
of somebody deciding 6 months from now
you know my bad let's start collecting
again and that becomes very um
awkward actually I think that's about
all representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair thank
you commissioner thank you for being
here um on the fiscal note it says um on
the second page due to previous
legislative changes collections have
declined significantly can you touch
upon that and
why why those changes resulted in a
decline in in um
Revenue so the the two changes and and
representative sure outlined them um a
little bit I think the two changes the
the the one is that we used to do the
determination um uh our our staff would
would go in and meet and do a
determination and and the presumption
was uh something along the lines of you
can't pay today but you know when you
get a job you can pay and we would tend
to collect from more people the second
is now you can only collect if they were
found guilty
which is a small fraction of cases so
we're collecting on many many many fewer
cases and and judges you know we
operated on the presumption I think
along the lines of our job is to figure
out a way to recoup something and I
think the judges probably have a
slightly different perspective but it's
declined I would say this to you every
monthly collection this is something I
look at has been lower than the same
month the prior year for four straight
years maybe five actually now
in in this is the fifth fiscal year
we're doing that so there's a it's going
down and and if you don't repeal it it
will keep going down representative
Smith commissioner I I think you said if
I unless I
misheard um uh 2026 july1 2026 do you
mean 2026 or
2025 oh 2025 I'm sorry fiscal year 26
yeah so in our yeah
sorry good catch well I I I need to
demonstrate that I'm
listening thank you for that any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you for having us is there anyone else
that wants to speak on House Bill
611 seeing none I'll close the hearing
on House Bill 611 and I think that's all
we have for today so
John e